Guten Morgen Linus.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik mit der Folge dreihunderteinundsechzig und ich weiß nicht, welche Folge des Netzpolitik Org Podcast.
Auch nicht, aber wir machen diese mal ein Crossover und wir haben drei Gäste.
Wir haben drei Personen zu Gast, wir sitzen hier zu fünft in der Redaktion von Netzpolitik Org. Mein Name ist Linus Neumann. Ich bin Tim. Und wir haben bei uns heute zu Gast als erstes Gilette.
Hallo ihr Eis, Gilette und so, dies das, ich freue mich richtig bei Computerdingsbums, ja. Ich finde Computer, ich weiß nicht wie geht, aber ich finde super, dass sowas gibt's.
Sehr schön, dass wir freuen uns, wir werden gleich viel über Computer reden, dann haben wir außerdem noch hier Frau Grischke.
Ja, trach schön,
bin auch hier, äh, ich muss allerdings sagen, ehrlich gesagt, das Wetter ist heute so kacke gewesen, ich hätte eigentlich wollte ick nicht kommen, aber dann bin ich doch gekommen, als ich das hier mit dem gehört habe, habe ich gesagt, na gut, äh, muss das sein, aber nur ich möchte ja nicht diejenige sein, die nicht redet.
Okay, wunderbar und außerdem haben wir noch da Ideal.
Hallo, ich bin die Einzige, die normal ist von den anderen drei und zweien, ja, möchte ich nochmal sagen, mein Name ist Idee Beider, ich freue mich sehr, ich bin Künstlerin, äh ich spiele verschiedene Rollen in der Comedy äh Abteilung gleich schon mal, ich mache gleich das in Rogley, was ich bin, was ich mache. Und ähm ja,
ich freue mich absolut hier zu sein.
Ja, wir sehen, also wir sind äh wir haben bemerkt, es geht hier also um Kunst, ja? Wir haben schon mal eine Künstlerin zu Gast und zwar in der
glaub die ist jetzt mittlerweile national bekannt, kann man sagen aber nur ein Teil ihres Publikums kennt sie von ihrer Kunst, ein anderer Teil kennt sie, weil sie quasi
Naziopfer ist, wenn man mal sagen und darüber wollen wir heute reden, aber nicht nur, sondern wir wollen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen sagen, ja worin besteht die Kunst
und wie wird man von einer YouTube Influencerin zu einer richtigen Künstlerin, wo man auch davon leben kann und wenn man am Anfang drüber reden und dann wollen wir ein bisschen darauf kommen, ja wie landet man
auf äh Nazi-Todeslisten, wie geht man damit um? Welche Rolle spielt die Polizei? Und also sozusagen von bisschen schöneren Themen zu etwas ernsteren.
Also ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können, dass äh ähm äh Nazis mich irgendwann mal fame machen,
das hätte ich mir wirklich nicht vor, also alleine schon rein voller Ideologie, hätte ich gedacht, sie würden alles tun, damit man mich nicht hört
Aber dass sie mich jetzt so exponieren, eigentlich haben sie ja dafür gesorgt, dass man Erfolg nochmal ein bisschen äh höher gegangen ist. Allerdings leider eben nicht für meine Kunst, sondern eher dann für meine aktivistischen Sachen, ähm die ja auch eine Rolle in meiner Kunst spielen. Ich fange mal von Anfang an an.
Ähm ich habe äh zwei äh zweitausendzwölf im Dezember ähm äh ein mit meiner Mutter, die kam aus der Türkei.
Und ähm meine Mutter hat zu mir gesagt, warum bist denn du so erfolglos,
Also es es war aber auch echt faszinierend. Ich war wirklich auf jedem Level erfolglos. Also weder hat dick einen Freund, noch hat dicken Job, noch hatte ich eine Perspektive, noch hatte ich irgendwie,
Also wirklich, wenn man, wenn man von allem in Leben jeder lieben Lebensbereich war minus ähm und dann kann ich verstehen, die war, die hat sich Sorgen gemacht, die sagt, weißt du, a,
Weiß ich nicht, fünfzig denken Mütter, sie sterben und sie müssen dann dafür sorgen, dass die Kinder lebensfähig sind. Also
davor ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, aber weil sie sind ja noch da. Aber danach ist es schlimm. Also sie hat das wirklich nicht gesagt, um mich äh zu ärgern, sondern sie hat äh das gesagt, weil sie sich Sorgen macht, was was passiert in meinem Kind, wenn ich gehe? So und dann hat sie mich hat sie mir das gesagt und dann habe ich gesagt, weißt du was, Mama, ich probiere und ich mache on Tour,
Aber tut mir leid, det ist ein Naziland. Ich komme hier nicht durch, die wollen keine Kanacken,
Und wenn, dann wollen sie sie nur so, wie sie sie, wenn wir sich vorstellen, aber nicht so, wie ich bin. Und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, das bist du selber.
So, was ist jetzt willst darauf antworten? Weißt du, es ist natürlich auch, ist ja auch ein Teil der Wahrheit,
ist man ist immer alles selber auch, ja? So wurde ich ja auch erzogen. Man hat seine eigene Verantwortung zu tragen und sein eigenes Dings. Aber ähm
ich konnte ihr das ja auch nicht weiter erklären und zu der Zeit habe ich gerade an Schulen gearbeitet. Ich habe also zu der Zeit gerade an der Nürtingen Grundschule in Kreuzberg gearbeitet, das ist jetzt auch schon.
Zehn Jahre ist es,
Genau. Ja, also ja, also ich bin keine ausgebildete Sozialarbeiterin, aber ich habe viele in dem Bereich gearbeitet und dann kommt man ja auch so als, ne, Quereinsteiger rein äh und habe zeitgleich auch in der Rüdlichschule gearbeite,
Das heißt, ich habe das erste Mal.
Für die Nicht-Berliner, dass eine Neuköllner Schule, die hier bekannt wurde, weil sie besonders viele Probleme hatte mit Gewalt und ein bisschen mit Drogen.
Ja, ja, ja, na ja, eigentlich.
Jahren irgendwie war das, ne? Da wurde zehn.
Skandal.
Doch die Lea, die dessen Lehrerinnen und Kollegium hat sich irgendwie geweigert da weiter Unterricht zu machen oder so.
Ja, dann haben sie Mülleimer außer Dings geschmissen. Jetzt äh muss man allerdings sagen, ähm äh tatsächlich ist es so, dass natürlich, ich war ja da und es sind ganz normale Schüler.
Bis auf das sie halt sich permanent schminken die Mädchen, aber ansonsten sind's ganz normale Schüler,
auch relativ easy händelbar, aber was natürlich an so einer Schule und das ist ja auch ein Problem, was wir haben, nicht nur in Berlin. Was natürlich passiert ist, dadurch, dass es ähm immer mehr äh ähm migrantische Kinder gibt, ne, also dadurch, dass die gebotenen Rate der Deutschen eigentlich relativ stark,
gegangen ist.
Wir können uns nicht vermehren.
Äh ja, dann brauche ich ein bisschen Unterstützung. Ich bin ja da. Aber ähm äh,
tatsächlich sieht's jetzt so aus. Es sind wahnsinnig viele Migranten äh an Schulen und es gibt aber nur deutsche Lehrer. Und da fängt etwas an und das ist sehr interessant, ne? Also ich sehe
kann wirklich sagen, es ist überhaupt niemand Schuld
es ist einfach nur sehr herzerreißende Situation. Der deutsche Lehrer wird angehalten, Multikulti zu sein. Was stellt man sich darunter vor? Man versucht den Kindern zu erklären, ihr kommt alle von woanders her. Die
Kinder wollen aber dazu gehören und Deutsch sein. Das heißt, die, dann stehst du, gibt's so Situationen, dann sagt, macht sie die Weltkarte auf und dann sagt sie so, Ahmed, du kommst ja von hier, du gehörst nicht zu uns,
die meint es nicht böse. Sie erweiß einfach nicht, wie sie diese beiden Sachen übereinbringen sollen. Einerseits politisch Multikulti sein
und das auch irgendwie fördern und auf der anderen Seite ähm die Zugehörigkeit der Kinder fördern. Das ist eine ganz schwierige Sache und das heißt, die Kinder merken schnell, ähm o,
die ist,
keine von uns. Ich hab wirklich in dieser fünften Klasse an der nötigen Grundschule vor zehn Jahren gesessen und die Kinder ähm äh haben sich gemeldet irgendwas richtig gesagt, dann gucken die zu mir, ob ich das gut finde, nicht, ob die Lehrerin das gut findet. Und das ist ein Problem
Das heißt, da ist ein Vertrauensverhältnis, da ist eine Distanz drin.
Ja, aber warte mal, also von dieser sozusagen beginnt mit meiner Jugend arbeiten das jetzt mal zu irgendwie kunst auf der Bühne ist ja nochmal ein Sprung.
Genau, also nur damit damit klar ist, dass der unfassbar viele Erfahrungen gemacht haben, die eigentlich der Vor der der Nährboden waren für Gilette Eische. Äh dass ich so spreche, ich bin ja fünfundsiebziger Jahrgang, das heißt Berlin damals, wir haben alle Berliner, ich
ich fühle mich als Berliner. Ich fühle mich nicht als Migrantin, Migrantisierte oder äh höchstens wenn's dann eben, ne, wenn ich so angesprochen werde, aber ich,
bin Berliner Leute, egal wo ich hingehe,
Berlin kommt. Und das war in den Neunzigern auch ganz klar und deutlich, diese neue Sprache, dieses ich schwöre über Fremdstellole, was los mit dir? Ich klatsche dir eine, die Stars äh läuft bei dir. Das war bei uns früher nicht so.
Ich als Künstlerin war natürlich extrem fasziniert, wie intelligent die diese Sprache benutzen. Es ist wirklich hochintelligent. Für den einen ist es natürlich Sprachverfall, aber wenn du ähm alles einbeziehst und ähm quasi die die
Synergien siehst, ne? Das ist eine die sprechen ihre arabische Sprache, aber sie übersetzen die den Wortlaut, die Sprache ins Deutsche, das heißt sie machen Sprachbilder
Und auch ich meine mit fünfzehn zu wissen, dass du eine Rolle hast, die du spielst, finde ich,
unfassbar intelligent. Das ist, machen die nicht bewusst, aber das ist eine unbewusste ähm Wiedergabe von dem, was sie auch empfinden, ne? Also sie.
Nee, aber du machst dich dir bewusst, also auszunutzen und daraus eine Figur zu bauen und also ein richtiges Programm, das ist ja nochmal also da kann man was aufschnappen an der Schule, aber das ist ja trotzdem noch eine Kunst.
Genau und da ist es eben und das ist eben passiert. So pass auf folgendes. Ich saß zu Hause, hab also die Kids nachgemacht, weil wir uns kaputt gelacht haben. Meine Mutter hört das und sagt so Idill, das nehmen wir auf und packen das auf YouTube, du wirst sehen, du hast Erfolg. Ich war nur so, ey.
Wartet mal, woher kannte denn deine Mutter YouTube? Das ist doch alles.
Meine Mutter, die hat Computer gehabt, da habe ich noch geheult, als ich den Staat gedrückt habe. Meine Mutter ist superprogressiv. Wirklich, die ist, die ist ja auch Mastenbildnerin gewesen, lange bei hinter Gittern dieser Sendung Serie. Also als sie damals rauskam, ist ja auch schon Ewigkeiten her.
Fernseher hat.
RTL. Habe ich auch immer geguckt.
Knast RTL genau da. Da hat sie, hast du geguckt.
Wird weiter und so. Nein. Wahnsinn.
Rass. Und meine Mutter hat Walters Schminke gemacht. Ja, ja.
Alter war geschminkt.
Weiter war geschminkt.
Okay, also das heißt, deine Mutter ist eigentlich Schuld, dass du dann irgendwann Influencer. Also wie, wo kamen denn die ersten Klicks daher, wo wie ging denn das los? Hab's da plötzlich irgendwie tausende hingeklickt haben.
Sie hat also angerufen, ihre alten Kameraden, eine ähm zwei Kameras bestellt, eine Fern eine Nah und dann hat sie mich dahin gesetzt und dann habe ich das tatsächlich gemacht und habe das aufgenommen, weil ich dachte, komm eh nur drei Klicks und dann kann ich meiner Mutter beweisen, wie Recht ich habe. Das war mein Plan.
Und hat sie dich auch geschmink.
Da hat sie mich nicht geschmink.
Hat sie nicht.
Hat sie nicht bei war nicht so notwendig. War nicht so dolle notwendig, aber so,
ähm äh dann äh es ist Folgendes passiert. Wir haben's auf YouTube gestellt. Ich dachte ja gut, ich beweise ihr jetzt, ich habe Recht, dann lässt sie mich in Ruhe für immer
Äh aber tatsächlich darfst du deine Mutter einfach nie unterschätzen. Du darfst Mütter nicht unterschätzen, sie sind von einem anderen Planeten. Wenn du Mutter wirst, passiert was mit dir, du bist ein Alien dann. Irgendwas wird an dir anders. Jedenfalls hat sie Rech,
Es kam innerhalb von drei Monaten wirklich eins Komma drei Millionen Klicks. Das war für Comedy, für Musik ist das nichts, ne? Musik ist, na klar
aber Comedy ist, das ist schon massiv. Das ist ein Video, so viel Kli.
Also du hast einfach einen Nerv getroffen, würdest du sagen.
Richtig, ich habe Nerv getroffen, wusste ich aber nicht.
Hattest du nicht eigentlich Sorge, dass vielleicht die Kids über die du die du danacheff? Das das deren Gefühle verletzt oder das oder den.
Am Anfang dachte ich, das wird gar nicht wahrgenommen. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, dass die Kids das extrem gefeiert haben. Und ich habe auch verstanden, warum? Weil ich sie ja nicht demütige. Ne, also das mache ich nicht. Ich ich.
Position der Stärke herau.
Richtig, richtig. Also ich meine, eins ist ja sehr äh frappierend an der Eiche. Sie äh ähm sie liebt sich ja, ne? Also für sie sind halt alle anderen falsch,
Aber sie würde nicht auf die Idee kommen, sich selbst äh als irgendwie nicht in Ordnung zu bezeichnen. Für sie sind alle anderen nicht in Ordnung. Sie selbst ist Check.
Also und das ist ja auch eine eine ganz andere Haltung, das ist aber auch die Haltung, die die Jugendlichen mittlerweile haben. Die sind nicht so wie wir,
Wir wir sind noch so ein bisschen, also meine Meinung, ne? Also vor dreißig, vierzig Jahren wurden Frauen noch ein bisschen nicht so ähm selbstbewusst erzogen,
und tatsächlich die sind super selbstbewusst, ey die lassen sich, die sind emanzipierter als wir uns das vorstellen können. Ich gebe dir ein Beispiel mit emanzipiert, da sagt ein Mädchen zu dem anderen, ich habe zu meinem Vater gesagt
wenn er nicht diese Ohrringe für mich kauft, die von Echtgold, dann ich bleibe nicht Jungfrau.
Was ihr jetzt hier nicht sehen könnt im Podcast ist es. Also äh ihr müsstet jetzt natürlich auch sehen, die ganze ganze Haltung, Gestik, Mimik und so. Aber dann könnte der Mann in.
Und dann er hat mir Armband auch gekauft. Er hat mir Armband auch gekauft, damit Jungs Probleme. Ich meine, wie emanzipiert ist das bitte? Die wissen, das ist so ein Schrottkonzept, damit verarsche ich die einfach, interessiert mich sowieso nicht, ich nehme das nicht ernst, ich nutze es zu meinem Vorteil. Mehr geht auch nicht.
Okay, aber ich versuche nochmal zurück.
Wie ist der Sprung von plötzlich klicken da Leute hin? Ja. Zu irgendwann muss man das erste Mal selber live auf einer Bühne stehen. Wie wie ist sozusagen da der Sprung.
Sprung war folgender, äh also diese Klicks kamen, dann kamen Anfragen vom Fernsehen, sie wollten Interviews haben und dann habe ich gesagt, so jetzt renne ich einfach mit. Ist okay, mache ich einfach und dann bin ich.
Du hattest auch sofort Spaß dran.
Sofort, sofort hatte ich irgendwie äh was heißt Spaß? Ich hatte erstmal Todesangst, die erste vier Jahre, wirklich Todesangst. Ähm äh und dann habe ich mich aber überwunden und bin tatsächlich im
Gott, wie heißt das hier auch schön dabei? Es gibt hier so einen Cocabucherbar. In der Cocabucher Bar bin ich das erste Mal aufgetreten, habe die Videos live gemacht. Äh ähm.
Und wie, wie war das erste Publikum für dich.
Gott sei Dank waren die meisten meine Freunde. Ja, also ich hatte ein bisschen Glück äh aber es war schwierig. Es war wirklich schwierig. Jetzt darf man nicht vergessen, ich bin Walldorfschülerin.
Eine Basis, ich habe eine künstlerische Grundausbildung. Äh äh Bühne auf der Bühne zu stehen, ist mir nichts Neues und auch nichts Fremdes. Ähm aber das war schon echt, das war eine Überwindung, das hat vier Jahre gedauert, dass ich äh also ich habe,
nach jedem Auftritt auch nach bezahlten Auft,
geheult, weil ich mich scheiße fand. Und das haben die anderen überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen können, ne? Also es war, es hat wirklich gedauert, bis ich mich entspannt habe äh und gemerkt habe, oh, das klappt ja wirklich.
Der Fernseheffekt, also ich meine, YouTube ist Ankanal, dann hat man die Live-Situation, dann ist ja glaube ich sozusagen eher so der zweite deutsche Fernsehen, nochmal eine andere Nummer, oder? Ja. Also da haben sie dich auch um Zug erkannt.
Absolut. Also da bin ich ja natürlich auch äh äh wo im Zug haben sie mich ergatter.
Na ich meine, führt dann zu so einer Publizität, dass Leute einen ansprechen.
Richtig. Das Interessante war ja
dass das Publikum, wenn es äh so, sage ich mal, ähm äh sehr schwarmintelligenz so, sage ich mal, achtzig, neunzig Prozent Deutsch war, was beim deutschen Publikum ja im Ferndeutschen Fernsehen so ist, ne, sind ja nicht wahnsinnig viele Migranten da. Dann machen die was, äh was eben Schwarmintelligenz ist, sie machen zu,
Das heißt, sie lachen nicht und sie klatschen nicht. Sie haben ihre Betroffenheit geäußert, weil ich natürlich über die Figur Dinge angesprochen habe, die man normalerweise immer nur im Schuld,
Modus ähm äh anspricht, ne? Du bist schuld. Das hat die Figur ja am Anfang auch gar nicht so dolle gemacht. Sie hat das halt erzählt, aber der andere und das war wirklich, also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, die acht Jahre waren für mich eine Offenbarung darüber, was wir,
Problem zwischen uns ist. Ich als Figur denke oder denke mit diesem Thema, wenn ich's ein bisschen leichter gestalte, ist es für den anderen leichter mit einzusteigen. Was ich aber zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht wusste, ist das,
jemanden, der als Täter bezeichnet wird, auch eine Dynamik losgeht. Und dass der nicht anders kann, als erstmal abzuwehren.
Na, wenn ich Rassist genannt werden wi.
Ganz normal.
Mir fällt das auch bei deinen Videos auf, wenn man sich das auf YouTube anschaut, das ist mein, also manchmal hast du ein Publikum, die gröhlen alles ab, ja, die gehalten sich halten kaum an sich fest, aber dann gibt's auch Auftritte, wo wo wirklich einfach,
tot, toten Stille.
Ich hab das heute nochmal als Vorbereitung auf die Sendung, da war glaub ich so 'n Auftritt in der Böll Stiftung, ja? Da kann man sich ja auch vorstellen, also das Publikum in der Börl-Stiftung, ne, das sind ja alles äh keine Rassisten und ne.
Alle Akademiker.
Kademiker und so Namen, du, du standest irgendwie vor den in einem sehr.
Lauten Kostüm.
Sehr lautes Kostüm, genau, du kannst dich dran erinnern, ne? Und und die saßen da echt so, du merktest so wirklich, dass die,
so wirklich da so, das konnten die gerade nicht verpacken. Das konnten die nicht verpacken.
Tatsächlich ist das, ist das so. Und das Schwierige ist natürlich, du kannst ja auch nicht greifen, weil sie sie äh kommt ja nicht und sagt sie, du bist Schuld, sie sagt einfach, du guck mal das und das machst du deshalb, du bist ein Rassist.
Ja, also was willst du auch machen? Und ich glaube, es hat die Leute schon auch verunsichert. Was aber wirklich gut geklappt hat und da äh das hat lange sehr gut geklappt und es klappt immer wieder.
Oder fünfzig Prozent migrantisch. Wenn diese Mischung da ist, dann unterstützt sich das gegenseitig. Weil ich glaube.
Die dann zusammen sich an der äh Show erfreuen.
Richtig, vor allen Dingen Deutsche sehen dann, worüber Migranten lachen. Dass die ja auch viel über sich selbst lachen
da wo ein Deutscher sagen würde, auweiat, das ist Auweia, sowas zu machen, da lachen wir uns ja kaputt, wir wissen ja selber, dass Over, aber äh sind natürlich auch in der Entwicklung, ne und und also zum Beispiel wie, wie, wie, wie Migranten lieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst, aber wir lieben ja wütend,
Wenn du rauskommst bei uns aus der aus dem Dings, dann wirst du deinen, die liebt dich, die liebt dich und dann sagt dir solche Sachen wie ich nehme dein Beinchen und ich reiße es raus und ich esse es,
Oder sie sagt sowas wie, ich breche dir den Mund und die Nase, du bist zu süß. Oh, du bist so hässlich. Also das ist so eine Art von, das muss man auch erstmal kapieren, ja? Und das,
für Deutsche sitzen da und sind nur so Kinderschutz, sofort anrufen. Ja, aber
Migranten lachen sich tot, weil sie das ja durchhaben oder wie deine Mutter dich mit dem Hausschuh jagt, weißt du, was ich meine? Und
tut weh, Alter, wenn du das Ding mit hundertsiebzig KMH abkriegst. Die sind ja stark, die Mütter. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die haben ja richtig Power. Ähm äh deutsche sagen, oh, war ja Kindesmissbrauch, aber,
Migranten lachen sich darüber kaputt und das entspannt den Deutschen. Dann kann er auch sagen, och na ja gut, dann ist bald ist halt da so. Na gut.
Da darf ich mitlachen, oder.
Kommen vielleicht nachher nochmal ein bisschen zurück auf dieses ganze, also auf das Thema auch auf der Bühne, weil wir, weil wir nochmal nachher, wir wollen mal über Cansa Culture reden, aber mich würde jetzt nochmal den Dreh
also wir haben jetzt so die Entwicklung ein bisschen gesehen,
Wann hast du gemerkt, du machst dir da auch echte Hater und Leute, die die können das gar nicht ab, die werden richtig aggressiv. Wie hast du das gemerkt?
Also, was ich gemerkt habe, ist, es war sehr interessant, deshalb habe ich die Rolle relativ schnell abgespalten von mir und bin auch als Edel beider in Erscheinung get,
äh damit äh tatsächlich keiner sagen kann, die ist ja, das ist ja so, ne? Also wenn du ein bisschen googelst und meinen Namen eingibst, dann siehst du, das ist eine Künstlerin, die das spielt
Und das war mir ganz wichtig, diesen Bruch zu machen. Ähm äh ich wäre wahrscheinlich erfolgreicher gewesen, hätte ich den Bruch nicht gemacht. Aber ich fand den, ich fand das sehr sehr wichtig. Zu sagen, das eine ist eine Rolle. Es ist ähnlich wie mit Gangster-Rap,
Das eine ist eine Rolle, das Gangster rappen ist eine Rolle, das ist eine Kunstform. Es bedeutet aber nicht, dass sie äh äh zu Hause ihre Frauen schlagen oder ihre Frauen als Fotzen bezeichnen. Das ist nicht der Fall, ja. Also das auch ein bisschen auseinanderzuhalten. Äh ähm
Äh das war so ein Teil diese Rolle, ich habe gemerkt, am Anfang, du kriegst ja im Netz von Anfang an Hass.
Also das ging sofort los.
Von Anfang an hast.
Das hast du noch nicht erwähnt.
Das ist sehr interessant im Netz, kannst du es auch irgendwie akzeptieren, weil da ist ein Gegenüber. Da ist ein Account
da ist ein Name, den könntest du adressieren, den könntest du anschreiben. Insofern ist das nicht so bedrohlich, wenn dir da jemand schreibt,
stirbt oder ne, und das haben die ja wirklich von wir haben ja teilweise kaputt gelacht über wie kreativ die einen beschimpfen auch teilweise, ne? Das ist ja auch tötet ist, bevor es Eier legt
und so eine Dinger. Also der muss ja selber lachen, ja? Also und das ist wirklich international gleich. Also da ist das kein deutsches Phänomen, sondern das ist tatsächlich, ich habe auch auf türkischen Seiten wurde ich gepostet und da haben die mich genauso. Ja, also.
Das wollte ich nämlich mich äh hat mich ja auch noch gewundert, also gab es nicht wenigstens von Erwachsenen Türkinnen äh vielleicht auch, dass die sagen so, ey, ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock, dass,
wie ich bin, verarscht wird.
Ist keine Türkin, ne? Ist schon, du warst echt der Deutsche, also jetzt sollten wir die Rollen auch selber.
Das ist ja genau dieses dieses hin und her, das Problem ist, dass wir immer noch in Einzeldenken, während wir mittlerweile ja schon dreivierfach geworden sind. Es gibt so krasse Mischungen mittlerweile, da ist er in Hongkong geboren, sein Vater kommt aus Kenia und seine Mutter ist Deutsche,
Also, ne, es ist, das ist so schwierig.
Ne? Ach so, jetzt sind wir auf Linus Fragen zu kommen. Hast du da auch irgendwie negative Kommentare bekommen, wie Sau?
Generell, sobald ich anfange irgendeine Nation zu kritisieren, ist scheißegal, welche das ist, kriege ich auch Hate
Also es gibt, ne? Und das ist das Interessante, es gibt eben auch Leute, die schreiben, du hast völlig recht
aber es gibt eben auch genauso Leute wie äh äh du, ne, die dann richtig beschimpfen und äh bei uns, ich sage immer, bei den Türken fängt ja ein ein kritischer Brief mit du Hurensohn an
Es ist er will nur Kritik äußern. Weißt du was, ich meine, wir machen uns darüber auch lustig, aber tatsächlich ist das so, du kriegst Hate von beiden Seiten,
jetzt ist natürlich der Punkt der, dass ich ja schon äh ähm,
auch, dass Deutsche mehr ins Visier genommen habe, als das türkisch sein. Das bedeutet natürlich, dass noch mehr äh ähm quasi das jetzt so aussieht, als würden deutsche Mehrheiten, das stimmt aber nicht. Also ich glaube, das ist eine Art von Bewusstsein,
die ein Mensch trägt. Kulturübergreifend.
Wie würdest du das die politische Wirkung oder das politische Ziel deines Programms,
Bezeichnen. Also warum machst du das? Machst du es ja wahrscheinlich nicht nur damit, damit man ein bisschen drüber lachen kann, sondern das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch wiederum nur ein Mittel für.
Ich nicht hatte von Anfang an war 'ne politische Agenda, das hatte ich nicht, das hat sich wirklich entwickelt aber ne? Also weil ich eben merke dass das tatsächlich eher 'ne aktivistische Rolle ist als eine
sage ich mal, klassisch, klassisch, künstlerische Rolle. Also bin ich auch immer mehr in die Richtung tendiert. Ähm äh äh,
jetzt kann ich politische Forderungen formulieren. Das hat mich also auch ein bisschen emanzipiert, diese Rolle zu spielen war für mich wirklich also das größte Geschenk Evers hat mich auf so vielen Ebenen befreit. Ähm da ich tatsächlich jetzt äh äh diese,
wie soll ich sagen, diese Konstruktion, dass ich das bin und darstelle, konnte ich jetzt endlich mal von mir abspalten und eine Distanz reinbringen. Das heißt, du kannst nicht Chilet Aysche sehen und Idyll,
gleichzeitig Chilet Aysche als Idyll denken
das funktioniert gar nicht. Aber diese Unterscheidung musste erstmal herkommen. Natürlich habe ich jetzt eine politische Agenda. Ich fing ja dann auch an, mich mit dem Thema Rassismus viel mehr zu beschäftigen. Das war am Anfang in meinen Videos nicht so,
Das hat sich entwickelt. Also wirklich über die Jahre entwickelt, weil ich eben aufgrund der Reaktion gemerkt habe, oh Dicker, hier liegt aber viel mehr im Argen, als es mir überhaupt klar war. Dass ich einen Nerv getroffen habe am Anfang,
war sozusagen wie eine Zwiebel schälen. Äh ähm ich muss erstmal zu diesem Nerv kommen.
Ach so, die erste Schale war so, okay, gibt Klicks. Die zweite war gibt, hey, die dritte war, okay, jetzt checke.
Los, genau, die vierte waren äh Auftritte, warum äh lachen die einen da? Die anderen da, warum lachen die anderen gar nicht? Äh was sage ich da? Äh wie kommt das an? Was passiert auch die Erfahrung zu machen äh ähm,
tatsächlich also ich bin ja in meiner Rolle mal weiß und mal nicht weiß. Ja, also es heißt bei Unterschwarzen bin ich auch eine Weiße. Weil ich auf jeden Fall weißer bin als sie
Ja und das heißt auch ich musste mal die Erfahrung machen wie das ist, wenn dir zu dir jemand sagt du bist ein Rassist,
als ich das erste Mal die Erfahrung gemacht habe, ich musste so lachen am im Nachhinein, weil ich habe genauso reagiert wie jeder Deutsche, dem ich sage, du bist Alrasse. Ich habe original so reag
Ich habe äh ich habe erstmal relativiert. Dann habe ich äh bin ich wütend geworden, dann bin ich traurig geworden, dann habe ich meinen schwarzen Freunde aufgezählt. Dann habe ich Argumentation gebracht, dann habe ich aber ein Bekannter von mir, hat so und so gesagt
Ich habe alles gemacht, was normalerweise ein Deutscher als Reaktion mir gibt, wenn ich äh sage, du bist ein Rassist und da habe ich begriffen. Dicker, das ist eine Dynamik.
Wir müssen jetzt aber trotzdem auch nochmal also okay, jetzt haben wir den die nächste Stufe, also du hast es jetzt so als Zwiebel beschrieben. Ähm irgendwann ist das jetzt aber von ihr kriegt der Hass ab,
zu einer,
Drohung geworden. Und die sozusagen jetzt plötzlich dann auch nationale Berichterstattung wurde. Also wo jetzt Leute, die vielleicht noch nie gehört haben, was du als Bühnenfiguren äh entwickelt hast oder überhaupt nicht wussten, dass du überhaupt was,
tust und da wir jetzt plötzlich deinen Namen überall lesen, also und auch plötzlich äh das in dein Leben eingegriffen hat im Sinne von dein privates Leben eingegriffen. Sagt doch mal, wer das jetzt nicht weiß,
Wie hast du davon erfahren, dass hier die Polizei involviert ist und wie ist sie involviert.
Also ich ich fange mal ganz von Anfang an. Vor vor ungefähr zwei Jahren circa zwei Jahre ist es her. Ähm da habe ich eine SMS auf mein Telefon bekommen,
ähm mit eben den Bedrohung von wegen du fette Fotze, wir schlachten dich ab, wir oder wir erschießen dich und bei der ersten Drohung war ich nur so, mh, das was mich da irritiert hat, war, dass es meine Telefonnummer war. Klar habe ich, ist meine private und.
Private Immobiliennummer. Mhm.
Ja, also es ist natürlich auch meine Arbeitsnummer und das deigt auch was dran, wenn du dir die aufbaust, ne? Also schmeiß die nicht einfach weg. Ähm,
Und da war ich aber irritiert, weil nicht jeder kriegt diese Nummer. Ja, also woher haben die diese Nummer? Und dann unterschrieben mit SS Obersturmbahnführer,
Das war so das Erste dann. Bei der zweiten wurde meine Mutter mit bedroht. Da haben sie ihren Namen dann auch geschrieben und das war eigentlich so der Punkt, wo ich wusste, okay, das ist ernst jetzt.
Okay, was hast du gemacht, dass du nach dem ersten Mal hast du es sofort auch versucht, irgendwas zu tun.
Also das erste Mal war ich eigentlich so irritiert, dass ich gar nichts wirklich gemacht habe. Ich dachte, ach komm ist egal. Äh äh,
Ach, wird schon irgendwie, wird dann, weißte, vielleicht war es auch ein dummer Spaß von irgendeinem Vollidioten. Bei der zweiten bin ich aufgewacht, da bin ich dann auch zur Polizei gegangen, ne? Und habe das auch zur Anzeige gebracht ähm.
Der Bus ist ja noch nicht, das wird ja auch mehrfach passieren wird. Du wirst ja, du hast ja gedacht, das ist einmalig.
Die Polizei involviert ist. Das war mir ja auch nicht klar. Äh äh so und dann bin ich da also hingegangen, da hat man mich zum Gespräch eingeladen, staatssicherheit
Schutz, Schutzsicherheit war DDR war Ura.
Sicherheit ist zwar eine Straße weiter.
Straße weiter. Ja genau, Tempelhof. Ähm und da bin ich dann mit meinem Vater hin äh äh und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich war total schockiert über dieses Gebäude
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt Absicht ist, dass man Polizisten irgendwie in so einem verwahrlosten Gebäuden sollen, die mehr Kriegsfeeling kriegen oder was was ist,
in dahinter, ey, das Ding sieht aus, das musst du abreißen, also das, da kann man nichts mehr, ey, das ist eine Katastrophe. Wirklich, also die das Abbruchhäuser Mariannenplatz sehen besser aus.
Na das kann jetzt natürlich nicht beliedern nicht so richtig verstehen. Da müssen wir vielleicht mal ein Bild verlinken oder.
Berliner verstehen sehr, dass das hier alles scheiß.
Wirklich, wirklich, ich muss sagen, also das
war ich so, wenn ich Polizist wäre, in so einem Raum arbeiten müsste, wäre meine Psyche im Arsch. Also, nur gut, aber das ist eine Sache. So, jedenfalls hat mir der Polizist klar gemacht, dass es keine großen Chancen hat, weil sie den wahrscheinlich nicht finden. Jetzt ist eine Woche vergangen
und sie werden ihn wahrscheinlich so nicht kriegen können.
Aber das ist ja schon mal sehr komisch, weil wenn es eine SMS war, war ja eine Telefonnummer drangebund.
Richtig und es war die Plattform fünf vor zwölf, das ist eine Plattform von der man freie SMS schicken kann und wir haben uns ja mit dieser Plattform auch äh in Kontakt äh begeben. Und die Plattform hat gesagt, wir brauchen einen gerichtlichen Beschluss, dass wir das machen dürfen wegen Datenschutzrechten,
aber natürlich geben wir ihnen die Nummer. Natürlich äh geben wir ihnen die IP.
Ja, aber es wäre kein gerichtlicher Beschluss, sondern dann der würde die Staatsanwaltschaft beantragen und ein Richter würde unterschreiben. Das ist also kein gerechtlicher Beschluss, sonder.
Sorry, ich habe da auch, ich habe das Vokabular dafür nicht. Aber tatsächlich so, äh hätte es laufen müssen und das hätte die Polizei ja durchaus machen können, haben sie aber nicht gemacht.
Also wir müssen sie auch sehr schnell handeln und sie haben im Prinzip gleich bei dem Besuch gesagt, auch hat nicht vier Chancen. Richtig. Okay. Und so zu sagen, wann war dir klar, das ist jetzt hier nicht singulär. Das wird jetzt hier häufiger kommen.
Nachdem ich acht Anzeigen geschaltet habe, wegen diesen Bedrohungen, die letzte oder die
nee, das war gar nicht die letzte, die vorletzte war, als ich ähm äh letztes Jahr in Frankfurt Möllner Rede im Exil auftreten wollte, da kam dann irgendwie, wie wir knallen dich ab. Wenn du die Rede hältst, das also war mir klar, jemand,
verfolgt schon sehr wasser. Ich mache und wo ich bin. Ne, was ja auch ähm äh krass ist. Also.
Was würdet den Veranstalter auch gesagt.
Logisch, das wussten die Veranstalter, was ich aber nicht wollte, ist Polizei drin haben. Wir haben dann äh Osama Security-Beantrager beauftragt, das ist eine Security aus äh ähm Frankfurt und mit denen habe ich mich wohler gefühlt äh ähm Wein,
Ich habe mich mit denen einfach wohler gefühlt. Auch da wusste ich noch nicht, dass die Polizei involviert ist. Ähm.
Ist okay, acht Anzeigen ist schon eine Menge und wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur immer bei demselben Revier, sondern auch bei verschiedenen jetzt, aber haben die alle auch zu dir gesagt, morgen hat nicht, hat keine Chancen eigentlich.
Na, eigentlich haben sie gar nichts mehr gesagt nach dem ersten Gespräch sondern haben's im Prinzip haben auch nicht mehr mit mir groß kommuniziert. Es lief ja dann auch über meinen Anwalt, mehr mit Daimagüler. Äh ähm und ähm es wurde einfach ein Ding nach dem anderen eingestellt.
Du kriegst ja dann schriebs, ne?
Du gehst da jetzt so ein bisschen so drüber hinweg, also der in den Nachrichten
benennen die persönliche Daten deiner Mutter. Sie benennen irgendwie konkrete Auftritte. Das ist noch so öffentlich einsehbar, aber auch irgendwie klar, da guckt jemand, ne?
Was ja.
Die eigentliche Drohung da dran ist. Ist ja quasi zu sagen so, übrigens, wir haben hier Informationen, die sollten wir eigentlich nicht haben. Das ist ja das, was,
Oder das scheint mir der Punkt zu sein, mit dem man da drohen will, ne? Was was sind da noch so für,
für Sachen gewesen. Also ich weiß von einigen anderen Prominenten, die auch solche Mails bekommen haben.
Teilweise auch nicht öffentlich bekannt. Ähm wo aber sagen wir mal solche Komponenten auch gefehlt haben. Das waren dann eher so.
Standard, ne? Hätte man jetzt auch fünfzig anderen Leuten so schicken können aber in diesem Fall ist es ja wirklich konkreter.
Ich sagte, was sich immer wieder wiederholt hat, waren einmal die Unterzeichnung, SS Obersturmbandführer
und die kamen dann auch in den E-Mails. Also ich habe dann äh jetzt müsst ihr euch vorstellen, okay, ich habe das alles eingeacht, äh acht Mal. Äh ich habe dann erstmal auf nichts gehört und dann war eine Weile Ruhe,
Ne, also ich habe dann auch keine SMS mehr bekommen.
Mal bei der Plattform dich einfach sperren lassen.
Nie, ich da habe ich bin gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, dass sowas geht.
Würde ich erwarten, dass du denen einfach sagst, pass auf, ich will von eurem von euch keine Nachrichten bekommen, fertig.
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich höre jetzt das erste Mal, dass sowas überhaupt geht. Also ähm du musst auch ihr müsst bedenken, ich bin auch wirklich ein Honk, was diese ganzen Computersachen. Mir macht das Angst. Ich bin froh, wenn ich Laptop ankriege,
Weißt du was ich meine? Ich habe wirklich gar keine Ahnung und das ist auch schwierig für mich das zu lernen, weil mein Gehirn ist so nicht ausgerichte,
ich bin nur rechte Gehirnhälfte. Kreativ sein und kiffen. Aber diese linke Gehirnhälfte ist bei mir bisschen äh unterfordert.
Okay, aber wer.
Also du wirst mir viele Fragen stellen und ich werde dich angucken wie ein Auto. Ich werde dir so wie was geht das? Wusste ich was geht? Also na so. Richtig, wir lassen.
Aber wir lassen mal den Teil weg. Ich meine, man muss auch, glaube ich, ist so ein bisschen, soll jetzt kein Blaming sein. Du hättest ja was tun können. Also so ist das überhaupt nicht gemeint, sondern also man könnte ja andere würden vielleicht auf die Idee kommen, sagen, sperre den Mister. Aber du hast ja erstmal eine eine quasi eine eine Pause gehabt und dann ging das aber weiter.
So und dann ist Folgendes passiert. Dann hat mich ähm äh ein äh äh Journalist angerufen von der Frankfurter.
Und der meinte Frau Beider, morgen werden wir veröffentlichen, dass ähm die Polizisten ihre Daten abgerufen haben. Äh äh in Hessen ähm und dass das mutmaßlich im Zusammenhang steht mit den Bedrohungen. Und das Interessante, jetzt kommt was Interessantes.
Ich hab das, ich hab also ein Interview gegeben ARD am nächsten Tag. Am gleichen Tag kamen die E-Mails,
Also E-Mails habe ich vorher nicht gekriegt, sondern nur auf meine Handynummer, SMS,
Ab dem Tag habe ich also, ne, habe ich eine E-Mail nach der anderen bekommen äh mit den gleichen Bedrohungen interessanterweise, mit der gleichen Unterschrift, mal NSU zwei Punkt null und mal SS Obersturmbahnführer. Da muss es einen Zusammenhang ge
Zwischendurch ist noch was Interessantes passiert. Das muss ich noch ganz kurz erwähnen. Ähm ich wurde im Sommer letzten Jahres angerufen vom RBB, Frau Beider dein komische Sachen von ihnen,
ist das eine neue Werbung?
Nee. Jetzt müsst ihr euch vorstellen, da hingen Plakate von Dunja Hayali, Enne Samani, Idil Beider und ähm Zarosan Chebli und da drüber stand ihr seid der Hammer in altdeutscher Schrift.
Könnte man nicht einordnen, was.
Wo hing das?
Das hängt immer noch. Ähm äh oh Gott, wie heißt das da? Bundesbundesplatz, Bundesallee, Bundesplatz.
Bundesplatz her.
Bundesplatz, genau. Unter der Brücke hängen immer noch diese vier Bilder.
Von Safsan Chepli wusste man, da man sich, dass sie auch bedroht wird, das war noch nicht bekannt.
Das war noch nicht bekannt, genau.
Aber die die Reihe der Personen ist schon.
Und was sehr interessantes ist das Wort, ihr seid der Hammer. In eine der E-Mails, die gekommen ist, nachdem ich, ne? Dann bei ARD gesprochen habe, nachdem klar war, dass die Polizei mitbeteiligt ist,
stand in in einer E-Mail, die auch ähm da wurde ich nicht namentlich genannt, sondern da haben die den Satz geschrieben,
Ja, hier wurde gesagt, dass wir Vergewaltigungsfantasien hätten und dann kam das Wort Hammer, aber nicht,
Und in diesem ganzen Text findest du kein anderes Wort, was so doppeldeutig verwendet wurde. Ja, also es gibt enorm viele Hinweise
Irgendwo müssten diese äh Plakate ja auch gemacht worden sein. Irgendwie muss man das ja. Also ne, da sehe ich schon auch einen Zusammenhang, der wirklich länger läuft. Also es ist eine, da da muss es eine Gruppe geben,
ganz intensiv mit dieser Polizeisache zusammenarbeitet. Also irgendwas ist da sehr, sehr eng verknüpft.
Hast du dich damals also als DFR-Journalistanruf aktiv entschieden, dass du, du willst auch über auch öffentlich reden, ne? War das war das noch irgendwie, naja, hast du da drüber nachgedacht oder war das sofort, ja, das mache ich auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, als ich die erste SMS veröffentlicht hatte auf Facebook, das war, das habe ich damals gemacht, war ich ja so, okay, kann ja sein, die knallen mich ab.
Das war vor ungefähr zwei Jahren anderthalb Jahre. Da habe ich die, dann habe ich gesagt, okay, die Polizei wird mir nicht helfen oder hilft mir nicht,
entweder können sie nicht oder wollen sie nicht worauf sie mich übrigens im Gespräch auch angesprochen haben, ne? Wie wieso ich das geschrieben hätte auf Facebook,
Ich so, na ja, ist doch die Wahrheit oder nicht? Entweder ihr wollt nicht oder ihr könnt nicht. Ganz einfach, entweder ihr habt die rechtliche Grundlage nicht, könnt nicht machen, weil ich muss ja erstmal tot sein, bevor ihr ermitteln könnt. Äh mit Bedrohung ist er erstmal hm äh oder ihr wollt es nicht, weil ihr genug Leute habt, die einfach ähm.
Während die sich da quasi beleidigt gezeigt von deinen öffentlichen.
Ich glaube ja, ich glaube, das war, es geht eigentlich bei der Polizei, was mir aufgefallen ist, unfassbar viel um gute PR.
Also diese gute PR ist wie ein Schutzschild für die. Das ist wie ein Anzug mit Krawatte,
Solange es gute PR gibt, solange die Leute Tatort gucken und alles ist super und toll und guckt mal wie toll. Die Polizei repräsentiert ja gerade in Deutschland ein Land, was sich auch identifiziert mit Recht und Ordnung. Da ist die Polizei die absolute Repräsentation vom Deutschsein,
Rest und Ordnung. Ja, also mehr geht gar nicht,
dass wir aber mittlerweile und ich meine vorher hat uns halt keiner geglaubt, ne? Also diese Sachen, die jetzt laufen, die jetzt auch alle hochkommen, das ist nichts Neues.
Jetzt müssen wir mal kurz einen Sprung in die Gegenwart machen. Also ich meine
Damals war der Bericht der FR, glaube ich, der Beginn von der ganzen Reihe von Veröffentlichungen, die jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen unter mal kulminiert ist in weiteren rechten Netzwerken, die aufgedeckt wurden in
Innenministern, zum Beispiel der Royal aus NRW, die plötzlich von dem totalen Hardliner jetzt,
dann doch sagen, ui, wir haben da vielleicht ja doch ein rechtes Problem in der Polizei. Also es ist ja eine harte Auseinandersetzung, die finde ich auch sehr,
Also die ist ein bisschen eskaliert, auch vor allen Dingen, weil sich die Polizeigewerkschaften da so drastisch äußern, aber trotzdem ist es ja ein gewisser Weg. Glaube, man kann sagen, dass heute anerkannt ist, dass die Polizei ein Problem hat.
Unser Innenminister Seehofer, der sieht noch nicht ein, aber es ist klar, dass er der rechte Netzwerke gibt. Und da gibt's auch Beweise für,
Person, aber erstmal ja nicht, weil du hast die Anzeige gestellt, passiert jetzt nix und die Bedrohungen gingen weiter. Also was wäre dann eigentlich jetzt eine Forderung, die man daraus zwingt, ableiten müsste, um Leuten wie dir? Du bist ja noch nicht die Einzigen, gibt ja auch welche, die,
nicht so öffentlich spielen. Was müsste eigentlich geschehen.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ähm ich habe ja, was ich ja mache, ist, ich bin ja schon ein Typ, ich gehe dann rein, ne? Ich ich quatsche mit
ich labere hier dann voll. Ich so, was ist mit euch los? Eure Leute geben meinen Daten weiter, spinnt ihr ein bisschen, habt ihr eine Klatsche, Alter, bin kein Mensch, bin ich ein Tier oder was? Dass ihr mich hier nicht schützt und ich rede aber auch mit denen, ne. Ich möchte also wirklich wissen, weil ich sehe, die Polizei, die als Institution ist eine Sache. Am Ende des Tages sind's aber alles Menschen,
die da arbeiten. Ähm und ich kann nur etwas erfahren über die äh generell Institution Polizei, wenn ich auch den Menscheninspekte nicht. Jeder Polizist ist ja,
Äh ähm oder geht dahin, weil er jemanden anderen. Ich denke, es
gehen schon tendenziell mehr Menschen hin und werden Polizist, weil sie irgendwie Macht und Ohnmacht ein Thema haben, ja. Aber ähm ich will jetzt niemanden unterstellen, dass er erstmal dahin geht, weil er äh um wen fertig machen will. Ähm
Und mir hat zum Beispiel eine Polizistin gesagt, jetzt zu Seehofer, sie findet es fatal, dass er die Studie abgesagt hat, weil sie sagt, jetzt sieht's so aus, als ob wir was zu verheimlichen hätten.
Die Studie müssen wir vielleicht erklären, werdet ihr jetzt, wer so überhaupt keine Nachrichten guckt, es ist Seehofer, hat mehrfach auch jetzt nach den Vorfällen gesagt, er möchte keine unabhängige Studie über Rassismus in der Polizei.
Ja und das hatte auch sehr klug begründet.
Weil das die Polizei unter Generalverdach.
Nee, er hat er hat gesagt, ähm äh Racel Profiling ist verboten und deshalb müssten wir das nicht untersuchen, weil es ist ja verboten. Was natürlich super und da muss ich auch sagen, da fühle ich mich also wirklich beleidigt.
Dann brauchen wir eigentlich auch keine Polizei mehr, weil da ist ja alles verboten.
Es ist ja alles verboten, das muss man ja nicht äh kontrollieren. Weil es ist ja verboten. Steuerfahndungen brauchen wir auch nicht, weil Steuerinterziehung ist verboten. Also sowas.
Verboten Leute zu beleidigen und zu bedrohen.
Richtig.
Also manche Sachen sind Meinungsfreiheit, aber äh richtig, ganz genau. Also das ist, das ist äh mit Seehofer äh also da muss ich schon sagen, das ist wahnsinnig Kontraproduktiv und das keilt eigentlich noch mehr und mittlerweile habe ich auch den Eindruck, dass das sein einzige Aufgabe ist, irgendwie zu spalten.
Na ja, bloß man muss schon sagen, äh andere Innenminister in den Ländern verhalten sich nicht so und er ist Teil einer Regierung, wo auch die anderen den Mund dazu halten, inklusive unserer Kanzlerin. Ich finde, also äh dass er sich rausnehmen kann,
muss man auch sein, also der CDU, der CSU und der SPD als Koalitionspartner ankrein.
Aber was ist denn nun zu fordern? Das war ja meine eigentliche Frage, was müsste jetzt eigentlich geschehen, um Leuten wie dir den Rücken zu stärken.
Mein Problem ist überhaupt nicht, dass das passiert, dass das passiert,
du mal auf dieser Welt verrückte Leute oder Menschen, die anderen wehtun wollen, wer weiß, was die erlebt haben. Ich habe wirklich viel Empathie und Mitgefühl, für Menschen, denen es nicht gut geht. Ähm aber was ich nicht verstehen kann und ich glaube, das ist das Schockierende daran,
dass diese Polizisten, die dann auch erwischt werden, erstmal gedeckt werden von von der Institution, Polizei und sie werden auch gedeckt von Staatsanwälten. Ähm äh wir wissen, also die Fakten sind da und sie werden immer noch,
man lügt uns also dreist in die Fresse.
Und schon zwei Jahren.
Überhaupt keine Konsequenzen, das ist das größte Problem. Eigentlich müsste so ein Polizist entlassen werden und zwar unehrenhaft aus dem Dienst, tut mir leid. Äh das kann nicht sein, aber was passiert ist, sie werden entweder zum Verfassungsschutz äh ähm,
weggelobt, ne? Oder in andere Bundesländer versetzt, sodass das Bundesland sagen könnte, ja, aber der ist nicht mehr bei uns ist nicht mehr unser Problem. Also diese hinhin und her Schieberei,
von Rassisten in staatlichen und Institutionen. Das ist äh wirklich oft, also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist ein riesen, riesen Problem. Auch bei Ukuldialo haben sie das gemacht. Selbst die haben ja eine interne äh ähm Untersuchung gemacht, ne, dass dieser Mann, dem haben sie alle Knochen gebrochen in.
Mal erklären, das ist auch ein ist ein sehr prominenter Fall, wo man versucht hat, über wirklich also mehr als ein Jahrzehnts rauszukriegen, warum dieser Mann in Haft zu Tode gekommen ist. Und der, also das ist ein zu langer Fall, wer den jetzt nicht kennt, muss ihn nachschlagen. Wir können ja mal einen Link reintun, den können wir jetzt nicht auflösen.
Aber ich kann nur sagen, es kam bei dieser ähm Untersuchung, die sie selbst, die wir selbst finanziert wurde raus, dass er ermordet wurde. Die Fakten sind klar. Es gab einen ähm Staatsanwalt, der gesagt hat, das muss zur Anzeige gebracht werden, das war Mord. Was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben in den Fall entzogen,
Und das läuft die ganze Zeit und das ist das, wo ich sage, das kann nicht wahr sein. Also es muss Konsequenzen geben dafür
äh wenn du so auf so einem rechten Film bist und nicht irgendwie Streicheleinheiten. Och, na ja, du hattest da einen schlechten Tag gehabt, hat halt gesagt, äh dass alle Flüchtlinge ins KZ sollen. Also, es muss doch irgendeine Konsequenz geben,
Und die gibt es nicht. Und das ist beim eines U-Fall ganz eklatant gewesen. Die einzige Konsequenz, die es da gab, war hundertzwanzig Jahre die Akten zu sperren, wo jeder sagt, Dicker, was habt ihr zu verheimlichen.
Was glaubst du, warum,
werden diese Sachen unter den unter den Tisch gekehrt. Ich glaube nicht, dass die gesamte Polizei von irgendwelchen Rassistinnen durchsetzt ist, die alle irgendwie schön
zusammenspielen, ne? Also das wäre ich vorsichtig, dass das nicht so ist. Dann gibt's wahrscheinlich einen Chorgeist irgendwie, dass die sagen so hier eine Krähe hackt der anderen kein Auge aus, ne aber die müssen doch auch verstehen, dass sie,
das Vertrauen in diese Institution massiv verspielen, ja? Also es ist ja
wirklich in weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung inzwischen so, dass du nicht die Polizei rufst und mit denen nichts zu tun haben willst. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie, also das ist bei noch bei Weitem nicht so, wie jetzt vielleicht bei der äh bei der bei der Black Community in den USA, die im Prinzip sagen so,
kein Umständen rufen wird. Die Polizei, egal was hier passiert, weil da da werden wir am Ende nur nur erschossen oder verprügelt. Soweit ist es noch nicht, aber das jetzt,
irgendjemand in Deutschland sagen würde, hier Polizei, feine Sache, das doch jetzt auch wirklich schon.
Na auch für dich, also irgendwie eine acht Anzeigen und acht Einstellungen sind natürlich für Leute, die auch bedroht werden ein Zeichen, ja.
Man muss da vielleicht mal ganz klar also du hast acht Anzeigen gestellt wegen der Bedrohungen, ne? Und jetzt gibt es die Bedrohung kommen ja jetzt von irgendjemandem, also eine Person oder Personengruppe.
Und dann gibt es aber noch quasi in den Bedrohungen persönliche Daten von dir.
Die von der Polizei abgegriffen wurden. Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, hat,
ist der die Person, die deine Daten abgerufen hat, die gleiche, die dir die Bedrohung sendet oder gibt es,
irgendeinen großen Naziuntergrund, in denen diese Polizisten dann die Daten füttern und irgendjemand anders schickt dir die Mails, ne? Das wäre ja so die beiden äh Möglichkeiten, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Weg von der Abfrage,
in deine ja. In Box.
Okay, darf ich jetzt mal was? Ich glaube, es wird mal an der Zeit, dass wir auch ein bisschen ehrlich reden, ne? Also die das, ich weiß, ich habe ja viel recherchiert zu diesem Thema,
und hab viel mit Experten gesprochen Polizei als Institution und als ne, also das vierte Macht als quasi Durchsetzungsorgan. Ähm erstens mal das ist ja kein Club,
der Heimatfreunde, das ist ein bewaffnetes Staatsorgan. Ich möchte
bitte, dass es an dieser Stelle ganz, ganz deutlich ist. Was aber auch klar ist ähm und dass das sehen wir halt in all diesen Behördendingen, das haben wir auch mit NSU sehr schön gesehen. Ähm tatsächlich,
ist die Struktur und die Leute, die in diesen Behörden arbeiten generell sind sie tendenziell rechts,
Es gehen kaum Linke zur Polizei.
Es ist ne also es geht nicht darum zu sagen es geht auch nicht darum Vorwürfe zu machen, sondern es geht darum wenn ich in der Zeit lese, im Zeitdossier. Dass also Polizisten gibt, Gott sei Dank gibt's die ja,
die dann
Aussagen und sagen, na ja, ich wollte wissen, wie ich eben irgendwie äh meine Beförderung vorantreiben kann. Da sagt er mir na, du, hier ein paar äh paar äh ich sage das Endwort mal jetzt nicht, einfach einpacken, paar Kanakenkloppen äh und dann sieht das schon ganz gut aus mit deiner Beförderung,
das ist also der Maßstab, um befördert zu werden, dass also,
und ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig, dass die Leute das verstehen, dass polizieren. Polizei ist eine koloniale Tradition. Es ging darum, dass man äh ähm die den schwarzen, den man das Zeug weggenommen hat,
hat, dass mit der Polizei quasi abgewehrt wurde, äh dass die Aufstände machen, dass sie also quasi auf die weißen Kolonialisten raufgehen, das war die der Schutz der weißen Kolonie, es war eine äh äh
Söldner Armee für von weißen Kolonialisten, die denen klar war, dass wenn wir hier die Leute ermorden ähm und abschlachten und ihnen das Land klauen, dass das.
Äh äh eine Antwort gib.
Ja? Also das ist der Herkunft des der Polizieren und deshalb sage ich und das habe ich auch damals bei der Maybrit Illner Sendung gesagt. Wir werden in diesem System ähm des Pulizierens, der Polizei generell kriminalisiert
Das ist die Struktur.
Es geht hier um Struktur, es geht hier nicht um menschliche Eigenschaften oder um um äh man muss sich das so vorstellen. Weißt du, wir sind wie Wasser. Und die Struktur, in die du uns gießt, diese Form werden wir als als Gesellschaft als Menschen auch,
Und wenn du eine Struktur hast,
die rassistisch ist, dann werden wir auch rassistische Menschen werden. Ja, also das muss man einfach mal ganz klar sagen, Struktur und Dynamiken lügen nicht. Menschen machen Fehler, Menschen machen dies und das, aber eine Struktur,
einfach nicht, eine Struktur ist ganz klar in dein Gesicht. Und das ist das, was ich sage, was sich definitiv ändern muss. Entweder wir machen wirklich, wir verfolgen das Konzept,
von Polizei als Freund und Helfer oder es wird weiterhin so getan, als sei das der Freund und Helfer einfach gute PR machen aber die Struktur des Polizierens weiter,
warum ist es so, dass er seit Jahrzehnten Migranten sagen, wir rufen nicht die Polizei. Das ist nicht unsere Polizei, die sind nicht für uns
Warum ist das so? Als ich Jugendarbeit gemacht habe, weißt du wie viele Jugendliche, die auch bestimmt Scheiße gebaut haben, die auch Kacke gemacht haben, wie,
an den Stadtrand gebracht wurden von Polizisten und du stehst da, die erzählen dir das, die wurden ausgezogen, die wurden geschlagen äh ähm keiner glaubt,
Weil du generell kriminalisiert wirst als Migrant. Naja, die sind ja sowieso schon so
Und da äh das ist nicht nur die Struktur äh der Polizei, sondern das ist auch eine Kommunikation, eine Narrative, die über Migranten erzählt wird. Und die ja permanent jeden Tag befeuert wird.
Also Nordost spielt auch mit hinein. Und dann glaube ich gibt es einfach auch einen großen Teil der Bevölkerung, die tatsächlich, man kennt ja diesen Ausdruck, Happy Land, ne?
Wenn du davon nicht betroffen bist, fällt dir das wahnsinnig schwer, zu glauben, dass es so ist, weil du selbst diese Erfahrung nicht annähernd gemacht hast.
Na oder du willst sie auch nicht sehen.
Oder du willst sie auch nicht sehen, du möchtest ja auch an das Gute glauben, ne? Und du sagst dann eben, na ja, es gibt dann halt auch äh schlechte Menschen und wahrscheinlich haben die einfach auch im besten Falle, sagen sie, sie haben ja auch soziale Probleme und so. Dass das aber
beabsichtigt ist,
Das ist ein Punkt, den wir wirklich verstehen müssen. Es ist nicht beabsichtigt, dass wir hier friedlich leben. Das ist strukturell, überhaupt gar nicht angelegt.
Jetzt klingt das fast so, als wäre der der Ursprung allen Rassismus, die Polizei.
Nein, das ist ein Teil. Ich habe nur die historische, das ist nicht, das ist nicht der Ursprung, das ist ein Teil
polizieren, mir war wichtig zu verstehen, woher kommt die Polizei? Äh ich meine, weißt du das, wo der Ursprung der Polizei ist, wusstest du nicht, siehst du, wusste ich auch nicht. Aber ich finde, es ist sehr wichtig, gerade in diesen Zeiten den Zusammenhang herzustellen, dass es schon auch was mit
einer kolonialen Tradition hat und Kolonialisierung bedeutet, äh andere Menschen zu unterjochen,
Das heißt kolonialisieren. Also das heißt, ne, die Strukturen, wenn wir die ins Heute übertragen und sie anders nennen, ist die Struktur die gleiche und das gleiche Ergebnis wird kommen.
Jetzt, also ich würde prinzipiell vermuten, so dass wir schon wahrscheinlich eine Polizei brauchen. Ähm,
Wäre halt schön, wenn die sich um die richtigen Probleme kümmern würde, ne? Das äh also da,
Da denke ich, ist doch wahrscheinlich die Verzerrung, ne? Also das eben Polizisten bestimmte Formen der Kriminalität äh verfolgen, weil sie einfach verfolgbar sind und die aber bei bestimmten,
Personengruppen davon eben schwerer betroffen sind als andere, ne? Also ich ich habe mit der Polizei selten Ärger,
meine Frisur führt dazu, wenn ich mit der Polizei zu tun habe, dass die mich sofort Scheiße behandeln
Ja, also in der Regel, wenn ich eine Mütze aufhabe, sieht, sieht det besser aus. Ja, habe ich dessen super Erfahrung gehabt mit einem Polizisten, aber echt mit Net, der hat mir Tipps gegeben, wo ich mit meinem Fahrrad nicht langfahren muss, weil er da steht und Fahrräder rauszieht und der hatte ein paar Sachen an meinem Fahrrad zu beanstanden
die ich so nicht gesehen habe
ja? Und dann hat er mir gesagt, dann fährst du am besten da und da nicht lang, weil da da hole ich dich dann sonst morgen. Äh fand ich sehr nett, ne? Der, aber da hatte ich auch eine Mütze auf. Und ich denke, dass der ähm.
Ne, dass der irgendwie in so einer Situation war, dass er da war der wirklich
Ja, in einer gewissen Weise Freund und Helfer, ne? War für mich auch eine ganz komische Erfahrung. Aber jetzt so, ich glaube, dass das eine Erfahrung ist, die sagen wir mal, bestimmte Communitys in Kreuzberg, Neukölln oder so, ne oder Gillette hätte die Erfahrung nicht gemacht
ne, der die kommen einfach nicht zueinander. Und jetzt frage ich mich doch eigentlich wenn wir sagen, wir wollen, wir brauchen eine Polizei, ja,
oder wir wir werden die so schnell nicht los, sagen wir mal so. Da muss man sich doch eigentlich überlegen, was mache ich mit Menschen, die in so einer
Rolle sind. Ja, wenn ich sage, hier, wir haben hier eine Demokratie und wir haben hier Leute, denen geben dem Vertrauen so gut, dass wir den Knüppeln eine Knarre geben und ein Schild und einen Helm und.
Datenbanken.
Und Datenbanken, ne? Und jetzt da wäre nämlich jetzt so aus der Informatikperspektive dann meine Frage. Ähm,
diese Datenzugriffe können ja nicht zugeordnet werden. Die sagen ja jetzt irgendwie ja wir wissen, das war ein Computer irgendwo in Hessen,
von denen ihre Daten abgegriffen wurden, aber eh keine Ahnung wer am Ende von dem Computer saß, ne? Und das ist natürlich also.
Du kannst an keinem Geldautomaten Geld abheben, um äh ohne das Foto von dir gemacht wird, ne? Du kannst in keiner kommst in keine U-Bahn rein, ohne dass ein Video von dir gedreht wird, aber eine eine,
eine weltene deutschlandweite Datenbank wurde private Personendaten rauskriegst. Das kannst du einfach machen.
Seit zwei Jahren machen. Also man muss ja sehen, wir haben ja auch schon, also wir reden über viele Monate.
Leck ist und der den äh äh in Form in Formant für Journalisten ist, als dass sie versuchen werden das zu ändern. Das sage ich dir hier und heute, das wird nicht passieren,
Also diese Willkürlichkeit der Polizei. Ähm ich glaube, da müssen wir langsam mal mit dem Märchen aufhören. Es ist tatsächlich so, äh ähm äh beim Comex-Skandal oder bei Philipp Amtor kommt kein Polizist.
Das heißt weiße Kriminalität. Ja. Mit der Weiße zu tun haben.
Plett unbeleuchtet. Aber die Idee entsteht, dass wenn man hier äh ähm äh ständig irgendeinen Kanacken dabei, dass man sich um Kriminalität kümmern würde. Das ist ein Konstrukt, das nicht stimmt. Das ist einfach eine Lüge,
Also das heißt, ähm, wenn du mit als weiße Frau aufm Opernplatz in Frankfurt stehst und fünfzehn Gramm Koks dabei hast, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du kontrolliert wirst, ist null,
wenn du als Migranten nur da lang gehst, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du kontrolliert wirst, ist einhunderttausend Prozent.
Untertitel verdienen Natascha auch noch Koks finden, weil sie es selber in der Hand hatten oder so, ne.
Also ja. Also verstehst du was ich meine? Also das ist so derartig auffällig, ähm äh dass man da jetzt nicht mehr und er ist daran jetzt die weiße Frau mit dem Koks dranschuld, nein, na ganz bestimmt nicht.
Aber jetzt hast du uns ja nochmal kurz weg. Wenn ihr mal kurz ich findet, hat sich ja was getan in den letzten paar Wochen. Also einer der Hardliner,
ich nehme mal den normalen Erzbeispiel neben Herbert Reul aus NRW. Ich meine ich habe den erlebt, wie das neue Polizeigesetz da durchgedrückt wurde und wie der argumentiert,
Herbert Röhl hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, äh nachdem er die neuen Beweise bekommen hat für ganz
klar rechtsextreme Polizisten. Jetzt muss aber titan werden. Also mir scheint ja, es gibt zumindest in Teilen auch der Spitzenpolitik ein gewisses Umdenken, die sie, die jetzt merken, okay, wir haben da wirklich rechte Netzwerke, müssen wir was machen.
Nimmst du dir den noch ab oder sagst du.
Ist glaube ich überhaupt nicht
es ist einfach nur 'ne gute Art der Diffusion, das ist Gas Lightning, mehr ist das nicht. Äh die haben rausgekriegt, dass wenn man zumindestens mal sagt, oh nee ist falsch, dass die Leute sich beruhigen äh ähm und sie wieder Zeit gewinnen, aber da ist nicht der,
Ach, natürlich nicht. Du kannst auch nicht einerseits sagen, wir haben Rassismusprobleme und andererseits sagen, wir machen keine Rassismusstudie.
Nee, das ist Herr Seehofer, sie ist ja nun nochmal ein ander.
Ist mir egal, das sind Spitzenpolitiker und die hängen da alle zusammen drin, das ist das tut mir leid. Also da kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, irgendwie oh, jetzt hat der eine das gesagt, der andere das, also ich meine, wie verwirrend soll das Spiel noch werden, auch innerhalb der Politik muss es schon auch einen Konsens geben.
Ähm und wenn man den mal einfach und Entschuldigung, da muss ich echt sagen, Seehofer ist ja eher Marie Antonet geworden. Äh sollen sie Kuchen fressen, ja? Ach nee, ich mache,
ganz nein es ich möchte nicht. Das ist es Amtsmissbrauch, was er da macht
ähm äh tut mir leid, das geht nicht. Also so kann man sich nicht verhalten. Und ähm ich verstehe auch wirklich dich tatsächlich nicht, warum er äh ähm und jetzt mal wirklich jetzt mal ernsthaft. Wenn das die Menschen sind, die uns führen in diesem Land
und der mir eine dämliche Begründung hinlegt, die beleidigend ist an meinen Intelligenz, ja,
dann auch noch irgendwie sagt, ja, nee, wir haben schon Rassismusproblem, aber wir wollen's nicht untersuchen. Was zeigt, soll ich dir jetzt sagen, oh ja, nee, die wollen was machen. Ach komm.
Wie wie siehst du vor dem Hintergrund in NRW diese Nazi-Chatgruppe, ne? Hast ja wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, dreißig äh Polizisten und Polizistinnen in irgendeiner Chatgruppe schicken sich da KZ-Scherzchen, ne?
Witzchen mal, ne? Und als sie dann endlich hochgenommen werden, Hausdurchsuchungen haben äh,
kriegen die irgendwie einen Nervenzusammenbruch und brauchen äh psychosozialen Dienst zur Betreuung. Wie groß ist dein Mitleid.
Guck mal, ich habe Empathie so oder so, ja? Also ich sage dir ganz ehrlich, ich habe richtig Mitleid mit Nazis. Weil äh äh Tatsache
kann das ja verstehen. Also ich habe ja auch die Erfahrung gemacht, welche auf Deutschen rumhacke und rum, das tut einem total gut. Es macht Spaß und es tut eine.
Anderen zu beschuldigen ist, ich verstehe das. Aber wenn man das auch noch ernst meint, dann kann ich nur sagen, du kasst mein ganzes Mitgefühl, weil dir muss es so kacke gehen. Jetzt mal ehrlich, wenn wir gut drauf sind, wenn's uns gut geht, willst du dann jemanden auf die Fresse hauen,
Willst du jemanden bedrohen? Dicker, sein Leben muss so scheiße sein. Das muss so Kacke sein
Weil ich kenne das, wenn ich glücklich bin, will ich einfach nur, dass die Leute lachen und dass sie auch glücklich sind. Und verteile mein Glück
Gott sei Dank war ich in diesem Leben sehr oft glücklich, dass ich weiß, dass wenn ich nicht glücklich bin, weil ich einfach nur, dass alle die Schnauze halten, die Fresse halten, mich nicht nerven sollen. Äh und ich bin eher bereit, irgendwie äh Leuten zu sagen, du Hurensohn,
Ja, also äh weil ich, weil's mir so kacke geht. Ich habe generell glaube ich, dass ähm äh Faschismus ähm eine
kognitive Krankheit ist. Das ist eine Wahrnehmungsstörung. Ja, das ist jetzt so äh ähm meine Erklärung ist es generell, sollte das betreut werden medizinisch, ja? Also es ist äh tatsächlich so, das wird auch in hundert Jahren der Fall sein. Die werden sagen, das waren damals äh äh
waren irre, aber man hat das nicht so einstufen können. Ähm.
Ich will nochmal kurz zurück. Wir haben jetzt wieder mal wir haben jetzt wieder Politiker-Bashing gemacht, wird es immer easy und bei Seehofer ist es easy, aber wir haben ja in eurem Fall zu,
Ich bin immer nur auf die, die öffentlich bekannt sind, auch eine Spitzenpolitikerin dabei mit Janine Wissler
Äh die ist ja sozusagen nicht Regierungspartei, aber sie ist ja trotzdem eine Spitzenpolitikerin, weil sie ja eine Führungsposition hat in ihrer Partei.
Hast du auch politische Unterstützer jetzt neben ihr, also gibt es wo du sagen würdest glaubwürdige Politiker, vielleicht auch Martina Renner, die ist ja auch mit betroffen, die ist ja vielleicht sogar noch eher eine Spitzenpolitikerin, an Janine Wissler. Also siehst du zumindest in einer Ecke der,
auch Unterstützung, also haben sie auch Ideen, wie man gegen den strukturelle Problem.
Ich glaube, das ist, das ist wirklich schwierig, das zu durchschauen, auch gerade für für weiße Menschen ist das schwierig, ne? Weil die da du hast einfach eine andere Geschichte, eine andere Wärme. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht schlimm. Ich glaube, wir schaffen das und das ist das Interessante. Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt,
Wenn wir jetzt jetzt zusammen machen.
Eine große Verfechterin davon das zusammen zu machen, weil ich sage dir eine Sache. Äh äh äh Migranten sind migrantisierte Menschen sind nicht die besseren Menschen,
Faschismus ist kein deutsches Phänomen, ähm sondern tatsächlich ist ein menschliches Phänomen. Ähm und wenn wir jetzt langsam mal dahin kommen,
dass wir das sehen und dass wir es zusammen machen und auseinander nehmen, aber eben mal nicht,
Wut, sondern auch mit Verständnis. Äh guck mal, die Erfahrung zu machen, dass wie sich das anfühlt, Rassist genannt zu werden, ist eine Act. Das war eines der wichtigsten Erfahrungen in meiner Arbeit,
Weil nur so kann ich verstehen, was ist mit dem anderen und wie kann ich das quasi.
Wie kann ich also für den anderen einen Raum bieten, wo er mit mir reden kann darüber, auch wie es ihm geht, wo er sich überhaupt darüber bewusst werden kann.
Und auch mal lachen sogar in deinem Fall.
Ja? Also zu sagen Deutsche sind aufgrund ihrer Historie generell schlechte Menschen ist der größte Bullshit den ich je gehört habe. Sie haben einfach ein System übernommen was
andere Völker schon längst vor. Die Osmanen waren die allergrößten äh Kolonialisten ever. Äh davor waren's die Ägypter. Rassismus ist jetzt keine deutsche Erfindung. Es ist auch keine weiße Erfindung. Es ist einfach nur, dass sich das Rad gedreht hat und durch die Industrialisierung die Möglichkeiten äh äh quasi Macht auszuüben,
andere geworden sind für weiße Menschen. Aber ähm äh ich möchte, dass das wirklich Deutsche verstehen. Das ist kein deutsches, exklusives Phänomen oder Problem
Aber was das Interessante ist, ja, Spitzenpolitikerin, Janine Wissler. Ich denke, was passieren muss, ist, dass tatsächlich Menschen wie ich mit reingenommen werden in dem Prozess des Aufarbeiten,
Wenn jetzt die deutsche Bevölkerung das wieder versucht alleine zu machen, wird's nicht funktionieren. Ist ähnlich wie mit der Polizei, sie soll sich kontrollieren, sie hat aber
ihren ihresgleichen eben doch eher Mitgefühl und versteht es, dass sie da Nerven zusammenbrüche kriegen und die haben ja sowieso so einen schweren und die bösen Kanaken auf der Straße, die sind so böse, böse, böse. Und jetzt kommen noch mehr Flüchtlinge, also diese ganze Nummer, die da aufgemacht wird,
ne, also ein bewaffnetes Staatsorgan zu bemitleiden, verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Wir haben was weggelassen, das ich muss das jetzt mal ansprechen, weil äh vielleicht weil wir das ja implizit angenommen haben, also,
Ihr seid schon erstmal oder jetzt wirst der ganz große Teil der öffentlich bekannten sind Frauen. Das haben wir jetzt so ein bisschen weggelassen und die Bedrohungen sind auch oft äh haben sexistische Unternote nicht immer, aber oft. Also würdest du auch davon ausgehen, dass dich,
Männer bedrohen, also würdest du davon ausgehen, die, die geschrieben haben, sind männlich?
Also es es fühlt sich sehr männlich an. Äh ähm doch es fühlt sich sehr männlich an.
Na, was, weil wir haben das so ein bisschen weggelassen, wir reden.
Stimmt, das stimmt.
Rassismus, aber sie betrifft in in der Mehrzahl Frauen und also ich meine, wenn man so die Texte hört, die sind ja teilweise bekannt. Ist das oft so eine sächsische Unternote oder überhaupt eine sexuelle Bedrohung in dem Sinne,
Das haben wir jetzt so ein bisschen weggelassen. Bei den Polizistinnen, zumindest bei den neuen Fällen sind da welche bei. Also es sind nicht nur männliche Polizisten in den offenbar in den rechtsextremen Gruppengewehren, sondern auch ein paar Frauen. Äh dennoch würdest du sagen, es wird auch das sind also das.
Großer Teil des Problemes oder sagst du, boah, na ja, in der Institution klar, da sind weniger Frauen als Männer, aber das mischt sich.
Glaube, dass ähm äh Frauen in so einer autoritär massiv autoritär strukturierten ähm Situation äh sich auch anpassen müssen.
Und das natürlich im äh äh Autorität in dem Sinne äh kein weibliches Prinzip ist. Es ist ein männliches Prinzip,
Auto nicht autoritär zu sein, sondern die Struktur, also das können wir im Gehirn konnten wir das nachforschen oder nicht wir, aber die, äh, ähm, dass tatsächlich das Gehirn des Mannes eher äh von unten nach oben
tendenziell strukturiert ist und das der Frau eher von von rechts nach links. Wir haben immer beides, immer. Aber es gibt, es gibt ähm äh sage ich mal Dominanzen,
Oder es gibt äh äh Dinge, die bei dem einen bisschen mehr sind und bei dem anderen ein bisschen weniger. Was aufgrund unserer hormonellen äh äh Zusammensetzung natürlich ist. Östrogene haben eine andere Wirkung als Testosteron. Und wenn du mehr Testosteron im Körper hast, dann hast du natürlich auch andere Struktur,
es ist wie gesagt gleich aber auch sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich ich warum, ich sage dir warum ich das sage, weil es natürlich auch ein patriarchales Problem ist,
Patriarch, Patriarchale Strukturen sind in der Regel hart autoritär
Patriarchale Strukturen bedeutet, da gibt's einen Papa, der sagt, was Fase ist und es wird nicht angezweifelt
ja? Das sind autoritäre Strukturen. Unsere Schulen sind autoritäre Strukturen. Du willst den Kindern Demokratie beibringen? Äh macht's, machst sie aber nicht eigenständig, gibst ihnen keine Möglichkeit vor Eigenständigkeit. Was Hausaufgaben machen, ist Eigenständigkeit, willst du mich verarschen? Eigene Entscheidungen treffen ist Eigenständigkei,
ich sie dabei zu unterstützen und zu begleiten. Und das ist genau das, was ich meine. Eine Frau kann auch autoritär sein, um Gottes Willen. Also nicht jede Frau ist empathisch und nett und niedlich, ja? Also äh das ganz bestimmt nicht der Fall.
Zuordnung der Struktur. Äh Frauen hat man festgestellt, denken schon, o,
vernetzter im Sinne, es gibt das Krabbenphänomen. Wenn eine Krabbe raus will aus dem Ding zieht die andere, das ist eher weiblich, ne? Bleibt schön bei uns, alle müssen gleich sein. Alles muss irgendwie gleich sein. Das ist natürlich also in seiner,
äh äh in seiner Ausschließlichkeit ist das nicht gesund. Du musst schon beides gut mischen können. Also ne, nur.
Ist nicht gesund. Da auch da fehlt, es fehlt, es geht immer nur um Balance und Ausgleich. Darf davon rede ich. Natürlich ist Rassismus intersektional
Das heißt, warum ist die Bewegung der Frauen mit der MeToo-Bewegung Bewegung der migrantisierten so äh interessanterweise ähnlich gewesen ist, weil die äh Argumentationen die gleichen sind, die Argumentationsg,
zu sagen ja aber dann zieh doch kein Minirock an, dann wirst du auch nicht, ja aber dann rede doch ordentlich Deutsch, dann wirst du auch nicht äh äh ja, aber dann macht doch alles so. Das ist,
richtig, richtig. Und da sehen wir also, das hat A eine Struktur und die ist, die wird einfach der, dem autoritären zugeordnet. Diese Art der Argumentation. Äh ähm.
Und du würdest also dementsprechend auch sagen, okay, also erstens wahrscheinlich geht sowas eher von Männern aus. Und zweitens richtet sich das eher gegen Frauen, weil die quasi da drin auch den schwereren Verstoß sehen.
So und jetzt sage ich dir eine Sache, was für mich ganz wichtig ist hier an dieser Stelle festzuhalten,
männlich und weiblich ist ein Prinzip, das einheitlich funktioniert. Wir können hier nicht sagen, nur die Männer sind Schuld, die Männer werden auch von Frauen erzogen
Ja, also und wir können auch nicht sagen, nur die Frauen sind schuld, weil die wiederum äh ähm natürlich genauso in diesem System auch nur gewisse Möglichkeiten haben
ne? Also es ist es ist deshalb sage ich es sehr tragisch
Es ist sehr tragisch äh äh dass dass wir so eine Opfer-Täterkultur haben, die haben wir aber nur, weil wir beides nicht zusammen denken. Ähm wenn Männer Probleme haben.
Es sind auch Frauen dran beteiligt. Wenn Frauen Probleme haben
sind natürlich auch Männer dran beteiligt. Also wir können nicht so tun, als ob das eine nicht mit dem anderen zu tun hat. Und das finde ich, ist in dieser Sache ganz ganz entscheidend. Natürlich ist es auch Skur zu fragen,
äh ähm äh warum migrantische Männer gewalttätiger sind. Die Frage müsste heißen, warum sind Männer gewalttätiger
als Frauen. Der Vergleich unterhalb zu machen, ist ja Blödsinn. Also während Männer nur im orientalischen äh äh Geographie nur da,
ähm kann man gewalttätige Männer finden, würde ich die sagen, okay, das ist exklusiv, die haben wirklich ein spezielles Problem, was andere Länder nicht haben, aber das ist nicht der Fall,
Ja, also man kann hier locker auf die Straße gehen und sagen, die Flüchtlinge dürfen unsere deutschen Weiber nicht angreifen oder anfassen, äh Zorie, Alter, wie viel Vergewaltigungen werden denn eigentlich von, ne, also das um nochmal und um dieses Intersektionalität von Rassismus nochmal einzuordnen.
Na ja mir, es fällt einfach auf, finde ich, also
man zitiertet glaube ich in den letzten paar Jahren deutlicher, dass die Janzen oder viele von den Rechtsextremen, die sich auch offen äußern. Äh das zirka nicht nur in Europa so, sieht man in den USA auch. Die haben auch oft ein wirklich misogyne.
Ich habe jetzt gehört zusammen, das ist die Struktur von rechts. Also die hat,
Struktur, ne? Und die hat eine bestimmte Dynamik und dazu gehören immer die gleichen Sachen. Gewalt, Frauenverachtung, Ausländerverach,
äh Verachtung für alles, was irgendwie äh äh Hafermilch oder Chiasamen. Ja, also für alles, was irgendwie außerhalb der traditionellen Norm geht, guck mal,
meiner Meinung nach sind konservative genauso wichtig wie Liberale. Aber jetzt dürfen wir mal einzig verwechseln. Konservative sind nicht Rechte. Also hier wird auch so getan, als ob rechts sein konservativ ist. Konservativ ist das eine. Klar brauchst du ähm brauchst du auch jemand, der erhält,
der erhalten will. Liberale, die liberale Dynamik löst auf, die will was Neues, die will neue Senergien schaffen. Ähm aber du kannst nun mal nicht mit ohne Füße äh fliegen oder einen Sprung machen, das geht auch nicht. Also beides ist notwendig, aber beides muss an seinem Platz,
kann nicht nachvollziehen wie man eine AfD als politische Partei überhaupt zulassen kann. Das ist das geht gar nicht. Wie kannst du denn faschistische,
Parteien wählbar machen mit dem Argument, dass das Meinungsspektrum. Ach jetzt ist Recht sein Meinungsspeck.
Also wir wir kommen jetzt ein bisschen über hundertzwanzigtausendste, also.
Nee, eigentlich ist es ja genau das. Also wie kann das denn sein? Und das ist ja die Frage, die wir uns nicht stellen. Wir meinen, das und das ist das, was passiert ist. Die Leute glauben rechts sein, ist eigentlich schon in Ordnung.
Nee, nee, wie ich, nee, ich finde, wir haben eine gewisse Diskursverschiebung,
Es betrifft den Rassismus, betrifft die Polizei, also hat sicherlich auch noch zu tun mit dem, was man so Flüchtlingskrise nennt, also ich finde, die hat sich ja was verschoben. Also das soll jemand, ich bin nochmal zurück auf den Seehofer oder so, sich hinstellen kann,
Trotz der ganzen Vorfälle und seit Wochen sagen kann, wir brauchen diese Studie nicht, hat der hat er damit zu tun, das sind offenbar von einem größeren Teil der Gesellschaft auch akzeptiert wird.
Also, wir haben ja eine gewisse Verschiebung, die wir einfach über die Zeit feststellen k.
Ist doch genau was ich gesagt habe gerade, das war exak.
Kommt, du bist ja quasi zum Freitag, kommt es konkret an, weil die Leute, die dich bedrohen,
wo ich finde, wir müssen auch keine Ausreden für die finden oder Empathie haben oder so. Die die kriegen das ja mit, dass sich diese Diskursverschiebung ergeben hat und also das ist ja auch eine Stütze, die durch
Wenn Spitzenpolitiker sich so äußern äh in diesen Szenen ankommen und da fühlt man sich ja ermächtigt, ja? Und die Trittbrettfahrer, die muss man ja auch nochmal beachten, also
So mir scheint, wenn man sich dann nicht,
vielleicht auch ein gewisser Mut, den man dazu haben muss, nicht laut dagegen wehrt, dass sich da was verschiebt, da wird es immer mehr.
Irgendwas jetzt zu am Ende die AfD erwähnt hat, also ich meine, dass wir jetzt eben auch eine Partei haben mit einer mit einer.
Erstaunlichen Zahl an Wählern, die im Bundestag sitzt, ja? Natürlich,
Ich sehe, dass sich die anderen Parteien im Bundestag auch verhalten zur AfD,
dir auch live in den Sachverständigenanhörungen gesehen. Es ist nicht so, dass da viel Zusammenarbeit ist, aber auf der kommunalen oder auch äh in den Landesebenen sieht es schon anders aus. Also da schleicht sich was ein.
Jetzt muss ich nur nochmal auf die Forderung drücken. Wat wollen wir denn dagegen machen? Das kann man ja wohl nicht dulden. Also wo wir auf der anderen Seite hier eine Entwicklung haben, wie werden
eine buntere Gesellschaft und das ist ja auch irgendwie schön. Und Deutschland wirbt sogar damit, ja, wenn du mal irgendwann die Panemi vorbei ist und der Tourismus wieder losgeht. Wir werben ja auch damit. Also wie bringt man das irgendwie wieder zusammen,
ob wir das jetzt zu tun.
Also ich sehe nur eine einzige was also für mich, ne? Den einzigen äh begehbaren Weg tatsächlich bin ich ja für einen Menschenrechtspass als Grundlage für alle Menschen auf der Welt,
Das ist ja für mich also ich finde, der Fokus, den der jetzt verschoben werden muss, ist vom nationalen, auf das Internationale. Das heißt, was ähm äh können wir tatsächlich tun, damit der Mensch als Mensch wieder im Fokus steht und Kulturidentitätspolitik
so nicht mehr möglich ist. Ähm wenn wir erkennen können, dass es ein menschliches Verhalten ist, dann reden wir hier von Menschen und nicht von Türken
nicht von Deutschen, nicht von Neuseeländern und nicht von Russen. Wir reden hier von Menschen. Und ich glaube, das ist äh in der Diskussion unfassbar wichtig, dass wir diesen, diesen das Menschsein äh mit seinen Eigenschaften in den Vordergrund stellen,
Das heißt, was will ich tun für einen Menschen, der aggressiv wird? Nicht für einen Türken, der aggressiv wird oder für einen Deutschen, der aggressiv wird, weil da kommt die Interpretation. Da kommt dann die Narrative, aber Deutsche sind ja nicht so
kriminell, aber die Migranten sind aber besonders kriminell. Das ist das, was uns immer wieder äh ja, also äh stoppt. Wenn wir den Fokus tatsächlich auf ein Menschenrechtspass als allererstes setzen,
wo die Politik die Aufgabe hat, unsere Rechte,
unsere Menschenrechte als Menschen als allererstes durchzusetzen und anzuvisieren, haben wir eine andere Situation, weil tatsächlich wir als Menschen in der Identität nicht mehr konkurrieren müssen.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt so eine Forderung, wo ich sagen würde, das ist genau wahrscheinlich eine der Gründe, warum Rechte dich als Bedrohung sehen, ne? Also.
Ist, weil ich bin ja, ich sage ja, ich habe auch gar nichts, sollen sie doch Recht sein. Ich finde, wir machen ein Reservat auf, mitten in Deutschland und da darf nichts fremdländisches rein,
diesem Reservat leben nur Menschen, die nur Deutsch wollen und nun äh nah und die deutsche Kultur auch pflegen. Was ist daran falsch? Ist da nichts falsch? Aber außerhalb des Reservats kannst du einfach nicht äh geht nicht. Ist global die Welt.
Dürfen die dann Inder haben in dem Reservat.
Sie dürfen gar nicht, sie dürfen nicht mal eine Kohle haben, sie dürfen auch keine äh äh Currywurst haben, das dürfen sie halten. Die dürfen nur deutsche Dinge machen. Und nur deutsche Sachen sagen und nur deutsche Bildung haben und nur ein wirklich wirklich Deutsch. Ich finde das sogar gut.
Aber was würde gerne dazu sagen.
Gerda würde ich sagen, super, zieht gleich hin, gleich, ja? Melde ich mich gleich u,
weil möchte ich einfach nicht, mehr kann er einfach nicht mehr, ja? Das ist doch kein Deutschland mehr, hier tut mir leid. Leute, wir müssen uns das mal klar machen, hier sind nur noch Moluken. Bist du mal vor die Tür gegangen,
Das ist hier eh ein Schwarzkopf nach dem nächsten. Ja natürlich die äh ja und dann machen sie hier Moslem und jetzt fängt schon der Musin an zu singen. Sag mal, wo bin ich denn hier? Vor fünfzehn Jahren hat,
keiner in der Moschee hier in der Moschee rumgeschrien nach draußen, ja? Ist ja furchtbar, wie sich das anhört. Ne, also ich bin sofort für ein Reservat, da bin ich für.
Also auf jeden Fall ist deine Kunst auch ein Ventil.
Oder? Wenn du das nicht hättest, wie äh würdest du wahrscheinlich ja nicht klarkommen, oder.
Äh ich sage ganz ehrlich, das war ein großer Teil meiner Heilung. Ehrlich, dass ich irgendwie äh in die Heilung gekommen bin, hat ganz viel mit diesen Rollen zu.
Ich brauche auch so ein so ein Ventil. Ja. Brauchst du nicht auch so ein Ventil.
Ja. Er.
Ich ich habe ja eins. Ich kann mich ja jede Woche über die politischen Aspekte, die mich aufregen, aus.
Ist der Podcast auch dein Ventil.
Schon, ja.
Ja, aber jetzt Tatsache, jetzt reden wir mal darüber, es ist ja Tatsache so. Ich glaube, was bei weißen Menschen schon drinnen ist, ist das ähm wenn wir jetzt weniger werden,
und die werden mehr. Dreht sich das System dann um. Und meine Antwort ist natürlich dreht sich das System um, weil wir haben nichts anderes gelernt.
Jetzt hätten wir die Möglichkeit,
aufzubrechen und tatsächlich was zu schaffen. Weil eins dürfte nicht vergessen. Kein, ich glaube auch äh soweit ich das weiß. Ich ich kenne keinen schwarzen Mensch, der sagt wegen der Kolumnisierung will ich weiße Abschlachten.
Kenne ich nicht. Also das ist gar nicht das, was sie wollen. Was sie wollen, ist eigentlich ein System herzustellen, wo das aufhört, was jetzt passiert. Migranten, Migrantisierte Menschen wollen nix anderes
Sie wollen ja nicht, dass äh äh ich äh das sage ich auch auf der Bühne, wir wollen nicht regieren. Lang macht mal eure Sache selber. Oh, tschüss, ist voranstrengend.
Ich meine, ist dir mal aufgefallen, Leute, die Herrschaften sind, die so Herrenrasten, die lachen nicht? Ich lache den ganzen Tag. Also so viel besser als deine Rolle nicht, ganz ehrlich, aber ähm was aufhören soll, ist natürlich diese wir haben doch alle diesen Traum von
einem einem Boden, auf dem wir alle anfangen und starten und der irgendwie gleich ist. Aber wenn du dann immer noch am Kämpfen bist, um deine Identität und deine Berechtigung hier zu sein
obwohl du hier geboren bist. Also du musst dir das vorstellen, ich lebe in einem Spannungsfeld von hallo, ich bin Idee, ich bin Deutsche, ja, nee, Entschuldigung, Deutsche, also aber nur weil du in einem äh Pferdestall geboren bist, also die Ratten sind dann noch keine Pferde, nur weil sie im Pferdestall geboren sind. So
sage ich dann ändere ich meine Taktik, sagt gut, gefällt ihm nicht, da sagt hallo, hier ist Idyll, ich bin Deutsche. Ja, immer fühlt, nee, ich bin Türke. Hallo, hier ist Idyll, ich bin Türke. Ja, nee, ihr fühlt euch nie Deutsch,
Und das ist das Problem. Ihr wollt euch ja nicht integrieren. Wieso fühlst du dich nicht Deutsch? Warum sagst du, du bist Türke?
Du hast mal gesagt, der Prozess dieser Integration geht nie zu Ende, ne. Also weil der einfach ist einfach unendlich, der hat kein Ende.
Richtig. Aber alle erwarten ein Ende. Alle erwarten, dass du integriert bist, aber wie soll ich denn integriert sein, wenn's dafür kein, kein Maßgeblichen Abschluss gibt
kann ich irgendwo kann ich mir das ein Ampelstempel vom Amt holen. Kriege ein Integrationszeugnis. Also das ist und das ist ja dieses das ist das psychopathische an diesem System.
Das Beste, was du irgendwie kriegen kannst, ist dann von mir aus heiratest einen Deutschen und äh und und bist und bist äh Ärztin, ne? Und dann heißt es ja hier die Frau Beider, Türkin, aber
Echt eine gute Ärztin, ne? Und immer so und in diesem Aber steckt so viel drin, ne? Ähm.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen. Also ich würde nicht so weit gehen zu sagen, ich bin kein Rassist. Natürlich bin ich in einem rassistischen System groß geworden und auch ich weiß Dinge nicht und auch,
äh sagt manchmal Sachen, wo ein anderer dann sagt, äh hallo und auch ich muss,
obwohl ich mich damit sehr intensiv auseinandersetze, kann ich nicht sagen, dass das jetzt ein äh nur weil ich jetzt mal drei Bücher gelesen habe, dass ich dann voll den Plan habe, das ist nicht der Fall. Äh.
Und das ist ja auch das ist ja denke ich, dass das ganz Wichtige an diesem Phänomen Rassismus sind da glaube ich, da geht gerade die gesellschaftliche Debatte echt so ein bisschen schief,
Wir alle, du hast es gerade gesagt, haben rassistische Tendenzen.
Wir sind aber eben auch keine Paviane, sondern wir sind eine kultivierte Gesellschaft, die sich bemüht, Probleme irgendwie in den Griff zu kriegen und.
Könnte mir vorstellen, dass einer eines der Probleme eben ist, ne, also als Rassist bezeichnet zu werden, du hast gerade gesagt, ist richtig, richtig krass. Also ist erstens eine richtig üble Anschuldigung, eine die auch also,
Erstens, genau und die tut die tut weh, die die ist erstens im Prinzip ein gesellschaftlicher Ausschluss, es eigentlich allen,
sagen wir dem aufgeklärten Mittelfeld der Gesellschaft schon noch klar, dass das nicht geht und ähm es ist etwas, was man nicht sein möchte, ne. Frau äh Grischke ist ja auch keine Rassist.
Die will ja kein Ende sein.
Verstanden Leute. Ich bin nicht dafür, ich bin nur national eingestellt, das ist alles. Das ja ich möchte gar nicht äh äh sollen sie doch leben, sollen sie noch ich habe doch gar nicht, aber doch nicht neben mir. Ja, also nicht in meiner Straße, doch nicht in meinem Haus, also äh sorry
das ist das, was ich meine, ne? Also äh ähm das ist schon so, das ist einfach so, dieses,
koloniale System ist so tief verwurzelt, dass es in unserer Sprache, in unseren Kinderliedern, in unseren, ich meine, jetzt mal ehrlich zehn kleine,
Wieso werden die weniger.
Äh ich spreche auf der Bühne immer davon äh äh also Kant hat ja den Asiaten an zweiter Stelle gesetzt vor, also nach dem Weißen und der Asiate da singen wir dann drei Chinesen mit einem Kontrabass,
OK, er darf drettchen diesen mit einem Kontrabass machen, aber da kann die Polizei sagt, was ist denn das.
Genau und dann vier Chinesen mit deinem Grund, die dürfen noch mehr werden, ist okay. Also da daran tatsächlich, ne? Also es ist äh nicht,
schätzen was das impliziert und was dabei bei uns hängen bleibt ja? Und auch ich komm aus einer Kultur die eben Kolonial und Kolonialistisch war äh und die ähm äh über Paar Jahrhunderte,
äh nee, also nicht fünfzehn Jahre, so ein paar Jahrhunderte, das Ding durchgezogen hat. Ähm.
Und dann kam eben die nächsten. Ich glaube, was wir uns trotzdem, was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, ist, dass wir uns, dass das ist ein Thema, wo du musst dich mit dir selbst auseinandersetzen. Und ich glaube für Deutsche ist eine Sache ganz schwierig, aus dieser
aus diesem Schulding rauszukommen, ist schwieriger für euch als vor uns. Weil guck mal, wenn du sagst, ich fühle mich, wenn man mir sagt, als Rassist, ne? Das tut mir weh
mir tut es auch weh, wenn man mich migrantisierte nennt, um mich nach Erdogan fragt, das ist so, als ob du mich nach Hitler fragst. Und dass das nicht ähm äh.
Du kannst aber noch an der Mach.
Aber guck mal, das meine ich. Genau dieses dann relativieren,
Das ist völlig egal. Es geht nur darum, wie es mir damit geht. Ich werde mit einem Diktator äh äh quasi in einen Atemzug und soll ihn dann erklären, weil ich ihn äh weil ich ihn ja kennen müsste, weil ich Türke bin. Das tut mir weh,
das tut mir weh, weil ich weiß, dass Türke sein hier als etwas minusmäßiges gesehen wird,
Verstehst du diese Konstruktion? Es geht gar nicht darum, dass jemand sich über Erdogan aufregt, sondern es geht darum, dass er mich mit etwas identifiziert, äh was was ähm äh,
mal für mich ein Schock ist. Und wenn dann jemand sagt, du bist ein Rassist, glaube mir, das, was du fühlst, fühle ich am Ende ein Ende, wenn man mich Migranten nennt,
wenn man zu mir Migrantisierte sagt, wenn man mir überhaupt keine Chance lässt, äh ähm äh ich meine, egal was ich mache, ich werde immer der migrantisiert bleiben,
Es gibt kein kein äh und das meine ich ja, das habe ich ja damit gemeint, es gibt keinen Punkt, wo du Deutsch wirst. Gibt es nicht.
Wie wie überwinden wir als Gesellschaft dieses Phänomen.
Eine kleinere Frage hast du nicht, ne.
Nee, kann ich, also ich sage dir, wie gesagt, Nationalität äh sollte ähm äh langsam an
Stellenwert sich unterordnen, dem generell ein Mensch sein. Ich jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, die Entwicklung ist ja interessant
Äh wir sind ein expandierendes Universum, richtig? Es sagen äh Physiker äh ne, Astroforscher sagen, wir sind ein expandierendes Universum. Das heißt, wir haben also in einer Stammesgesellschaft angefangen,
dann sind wir zu einer Dorfgemeinschaft übergegangen, dann sind wir zu einer städtischen, zu einer regionalen, zu einer nationalen, jetzt sind wir in einer internationalen. Was glaubt ihr denn, was danach kommt.
Globale, Interglobale.
Natürlich, ja, am interglobal ist ja, dann kommunizieren mit anderen äh Systemen. Äh äh also das ist ja die Entwicklung, die wir beobachten können, die wir auch nachweisen können. Also zu glauben, dass die jetzt hier aufhört, bei National finde ich sehr in von Faltin, in Fantil,
kindisch.
Also eines Tages werden dann äh Gilette und Frau Grischke gemeinsam gegen die Aliens vom anderen Stern kämpfen, weil wie die sich.
Ja genau, aber außer es kommen Aliens, die so sind, die noch schlimmer sind als wir, für die wir Dreck sind, die werden dann sagen, was seid ihr denn hier für Mist? Was ist denn.
Wie die Vulkanier, ja? Äh.
Kriminell, ihr seid ja total kriminell als Menschen, ihr seid ja total primitiv.
Ich bin noch ein bisschen unzufrieden mit der mit eurer Meterebene, die ihr jetzt hier gerade aufmach.
Unzufrieden. Nein, ah ja.
Ich will aber ich will ich hab.
Ja
Ganz ehrlich, wie, also.
Diese die Auseinandersetzung über dieses Thema, die verhärten sich gerade in der Gesellschaft und zwar auf eine Weise, dass die einen nicht mehr mit den anderen sprechen können. Es gibt.
Bald oder wahrscheinlich jetzt schon. Im Prinzip keinen kaum noch eine gemeinsame Realität.
Gab's die denn mal.
In der ich mich mit einem mit einem, sagen wir mal, mit so einer AfD-Wählerin befinden könnte, ne, die die stellt einfach fundamental andere,
Axiome auf, darüber wer irgendwie die Bösen sind und wo eine Gesellschaft hin soll, ne? Ich ich stelle mir irgendwie vielleicht vor, dass du ein bisschen äh irgendwie fortschrittlicher gestaltet wird, ne? Und äh so eine AfD-Wählerin sagt im Prinzip muss alles einfach dreißig Jahre zurück. Da war das noch in Ordnung, ne?
Und dieser Prozess, der wird ja weitergehen,
Und irgendwann wird der entweder darin münden, dass eine der beiden Seiten die andere gewaltsam unterdrückt.
Oder dass sie sich aufspalten, aber irgendwann muss das ja so ein Ende haben. Jetzt die Frage in letzter Zeit.
Finden wir in Deutschland diese Diskussionen über Cancel Culture. Ja, das also im Prinzip gesagt wird bestimmte,
Personen, es ist dann auch dummerweise immer an Personen und nicht an Themen wie wie ist dieses eines meiner Lieblingszitate? Jetzt riecht's gerade nicht auf die auf die Reihe, ähm.
Großartige Menschen diskutieren Ideen, durchschnittliche Menschen diskutieren.
Habe ich schon mal gehört.
Ereignisse und einfache Menschen diskutieren Personen, ne? Ungefähr ich glaube Elena Ruzwelt war das äh sehr schlecht zitiert gerade aber ähm.
Wir haben diese Situation.
Gerade so mit Bühnenperson auch und da da geht's ja auch um dich. Also wer dir da droht, die wollen ja irgendwas erreichen. Also ich meine, glauben die ernsthaft, dass du jetzt sagst, oh Shit, ich mache mal lieber was anderes, ich.
Aber weißt du doch nicht, weißt du nicht, ob ob es nicht Leute gibt, die wir nicht kennen, die längst, die nicht sozusagen diese den mutigen öffentlichen Weg gehen, sondern sagen, oh, dat lasse ich lieber.
Wir ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen, aber ich wollte nur sagen, möglicherweise ist sie die Ausnahme und nicht der Regelfall.
Es gibt also es gibt auf jeden Fall erstens Prominente, die diese Drohung bekommen, die jetzt nicht öffentlich gemacht haben. Ähm und es gibt eventuell auch Leute, die diese Drohung bekommen haben und auf sich dadurch tatsächlich haben, einschüchtern lassen.
Du ja offenkundig nicht.
Kleiner Schritt zurück. Nehmen wir, gehen wir mal Drogen, als das als das Extrem, aber diese das, was als Cancel Culcha jetzt diskutiert wird, ähm hat ja eine gleiche Richtung, wo man eben sagt, okay, was weiß ich, dieser.
Typ dieser.
Wenn wir sie ruhig beim Larben.
Dieser Dieter Nour äh.
War die jetzt doof, den wollen wir nicht mehr, ne? Oder der der darf nicht für Wissenschaft werben, weil das ein äh weil er den, weil er sonst eigentlich im Prinzip gegen die Wissenschaft äh hetzt, ne, dann gibt's irgendwie, wer ist denn da noch so.
Na, Lisa Eckhardt war jetzt aktuell.
Eigentlich die weiß ich nicht, habe ich nicht mitbekomm.
Weil doch in in Hamburg eine der Veranstalter gesagt hat, wir werden hier bedroht, wenn diese Österreicherin auf unserer Bühne steht. Ne, das war ja sowieso hat sich später.
Was hat die gemacht? Ach so, war der hat dieses Jahr einfach nur ausgedacht, wollte die die Hütte noch füllen oder was.
Da es gab wohl eine Bedrohung, aber die haben die übertrieben.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Aber tut ja nichts zur Sache auf je.
Wie sind deine Gedanken daz.
Sind ja nur Beispiele sozusagen, ist ja, du kannst ja auch ein Anrat nennen, wenn dir ein Anrat einfällt.
Ähm natürlich haben wir hier also meiner Meinung nach ist diese diese
die ja schon eine ganze Weile vorangeht, ne? Also das ist jetzt nicht seit gestern. Also wenn ich mir die Bild angucke, das ist ja schon längst nicht mehr auf auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes, sorry. Also wir können ja über Leute reden, wir können Boulevard machen, aber das ist eiskalt Hetz,
Das ist halt mit mit Boulevard nicht mehr viel zu,
Tatsächlich sind wir also in so einem Klima, was sich jetzt äh äh besonders zuspitzt. Also ich meine jetzt mal ehrlich unter Kohl. Gab's da Probleme mit Ausländern.
Rostock Lichtenhagen.
Nee, ich meine, ob's ob Ausländer das Problem derartig waren.
Doch ich denke schon, das wird auch unter Kohl, gerade so am Anfang, also.
Aber ja okay, kann sein, dass sie das als Kind einfach nicht so wage. Nein, nein
wollte, ich wollte nur auf was hinaus äh ähm tatsächlich ist es so, dass diese diese äh es akkumuliert sich eben nicht nur arm und reich, sondern es akkumuliert sich vor allen Dingen auch eben diese Tendenzen links und rechts. Äh ähm.
Was ich aber trotzdem sehe, also Cancel Culcha ist eigentlich etwas ist eine Verzweifelte, ein verzweifelter Versuch, das alles irgendwie zu balancieren,
Das ist für mich Cancel Cutcha, wir sind schon derartig auseinandergedriftet
Wir haben schon so einen großen Graben zwischen uns, dass das tatsächlich jetzt auf die Kunst übergeht, was eigentlich die Politik klären sollte, die Politik klärt das nicht, die Politik verhält sich schizophren wie Seehofer, sagt einerseits Auweia und andererseits na ja, nö.
Diese schizophrenie führt zu einer unfassbaren Verunsicherung. Du hast das Gefühl, du musst dich positionieren. Anders als noch vor zehn Jahren. Du musst dich positionieren,
und das sehe ich gerade in dieser Culcha, dass man also versucht auf einer wirtschaftlichen Ebene äh Politik äh zu machen und das ist ja auch sehr interessant, denn das ist ja auch die irgendwie die Wahrheit, ne? Also das heißt, wenn ich dich wirtschaftlich ruiniere,
Wenn ich dir wirtschaftlich äh äh fallen stelle, dann ist deine Meinung deine rechte Meinung oder linke Meinung eben auch weg.
Also du hast dann nicht mehr die Möglichkeit jetzt dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen durch das Internet ist natürlich eine gewisse ganz andere Öffentlichkeit entstanden. Jeder kann jetzt Öffentlichkeit machen,
Jeder kann jetzt was, ne? Also das Monopol von Öffentlichkeit oder Öffentlichsein liegt nicht mehr bei großen Sendern oder großen Medienblättern. Äh ähm,
Richtig, bin ein Beispiel dafür. Ganz.
Ne, aber warte mal, äh der Vorwurf, der kennt sich Culcha richtet sich ja explizit gegen Linke,
Also im Sinne von äh gerade ich sage das mal konservativ. Es mag eine Verniedlichung sein, aber so richtet sich hier.
Etwa Künstler bei Dieter nur dagegen, dass sie sich äh rechtspopulistisch äußern würden und deshalb keine keine Bühne geboten werden,
Wir hatten das schon früher, also ich erinnere mich dieselbe Diskussion als zum Beispiel äh Lothar De Maizire,
in der Humboldt Universität geklatscht wurde. Er kam nicht zu Wort, weil Leute ihn aktiv sozusagen kannst du ja in dieselbe Reihe setzen, ja? Also sie haben halt immer.
Lothar oder Thomas? Ich frage nur nochmal, wann man die.
Thomas Devizier. Dabei äh Verteidigungsminister und sie haben ihn weggeklatscht. Sie wollten einfach keine in der Humboldt-Uni-Expertität keine Rede, die von einem Kriegsminister gehalten wird. Und sowas Ähnliches, die jetzt auch, aber das ist ja ein Vorwurf an die,
Linke explizit, dass man also so eine Rechtspopulisten oder vermeintliche Rechtspopulisten nicht mehr hören will. Die sollen keine Bütin kriegen. Ähm,
würdest du den überhaupt äh anerkennen als.
Also und das meine ich mit Verschiebung auf die Gesellschaft, ne? Also alleine der Fall, dass äh die AfD tatsächlich wählbar ist, ist das Problem an sich
Wäre die AfD nicht wählbar, würde man sagen, okay, hier gibt's ein Heimatministerium, äh äh da könnte meinetwegen, äh, ihr könnt auch am Stammtisch sitzen und ihr könnt auch exklusiv eure Räume haben, wie Burschenschaften oder was auch immer, das kann man ja noch ausweiten, aber in der,
ist nicht der Platz für rechte äh Ideologie,
Und das ist ein Problem, was ich jetzt auf die gesamte Gesellschaft ausgeweitet hat. Äh ähm weil tatsächlich ähm da gehört es halt nicht hin. In einer Demokratie kann Faschismus nicht wählbar sein. Das ist nicht möglich,
Also dann ist sie krank, diese Demokratie, dann ist mit ihr was nicht in Ordnung. Äh wir brauchen schon eine Demokratie, wie sie sie auch erhalten kann und nicht bei irgendwie ähm äh ihrem Gegenkonzept äh sagt, dass das Meinungsspektrum des Arroganz,
arrogant zu sagen, na ja nun kann er ja äh äh ja, aber ist,
ganz eine rechte Partei in einer Demokratie. Äh ähm zu meinen, dass man hätte die besseren Argumente. Sagte mit Argumenten nicht,
das hat was mit Situation zu tun, das wissen wir. Wir wissen, dass wenn's wirtschaftliche Probleme gibt, äh äh ganz schnell rechte Tendenzen in Bevölkerung aufkommen, das ist doch nichts Neues. Das ist doch überall auf der Welt so
Ja, also und und das einfach zu verhindern ist ganz klar, dass man sagt, nee, ihr könnt ja Recht sein, seid doch rechts, aber in nicht in der Politik, ihr könnt nicht wählbar sein. Das ist nicht irgendetwas, was legal ist, äh äh um es zu wählen.
Ja okay, jetzt habe ich aber Politik und Kunst gemischt. Also.
Aber wenn ja, aber jetzt komme ich ja zu dem Zusammenhang, ne? Also der Zusammenhang ist, wenn es da nicht geklärt wird, geht's auf die Cancel Culture, das heißt, wie wehren wir uns äh gegen Rechte, die jetzt äh quasi Politik machen? Wir wehren uns dagegen, indem wir sagen, nee, wir geben euch keinen Raum
ja? Das ist das, was die Zivilgesellschaft machen kann. Cancel Culture ist Zivilgesellschaftliche äh äh politisch politisches Handeln. Weil am Ende des Tages ist ja jetzt legitimiert worden, dadurch, dass es die AfD in der Politik gibt
darf es sie ja auch in der Gesellschaft geben. Es soll legitim. Wir können auch jetzt Recht sein, man darf sie doch wählen, ist doch Meinungsspektrum.
Das einzige was uns noch als Zivilgesellschaft übrig bleibt ist Cancel Culture zu machen. Sonst haben können wir das nicht mehr. Die Politik macht's nicht,
Politik führt es gerade wieder ein, äh, äh, ähm, legitimiert es und gibt ihm Boden, ich meine, ich bezahle das, das es die AfD gibt. Ich bezahle Nazis, die werden von meinen Steuergeldern bezahlt und wollen mich töten. Das soll Demokratie sein und dann redet man über ein Erdogan
also wirklich so viel Lächerlichkeit kann ich schon gar nicht mehr hören,
mich so wütend, das ist so eine eiskalte Doppelmoral, ganz ehrlich, Alter. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht hier äh über irgendwelche Despoten quatschen, wenn man's selber nicht besser macht. Das kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden. Und da bin ich richtig deutsch,
ganz ehrlich.
Jetzt werde ich schon wieder nicht ob du jetzt in der Rolle übergegangen.
Ganz kurz richtig sauer geworden, weil das ist für mich unnachvollziehbar, dass man irgendwie denken kann, Faschisten zu wählen, sei Meinungsspektrum. Ey, das finde ich, das ist das größte Verbrechen überhaupt. Und wir sitzen hier und müssen kalt Cancel falscher machen, weil was sie sonst auch nicht loswerden, sonst sind sie überall.
Na ja, mein Eindruck.
Also du sagst.
Nochmal aus dem Bundestag schildern. Also ich, ihr wisst ja, der Vorsitzende des Justizausschusses war ein AfDler, ne?
Der mit der Machete.
Du hast den ja noch besonders also.
Der Trinker mit der Machete ist das, ja.
Der war doch oft noch im Bahnklo.
Stimmt, der hat sich offenbaren. Das ist ja also der Stefan Brandner heißt der, ne? Ein äh wirklich auch eine Kunstfigur, wenn du mich fragst. Der Typ,
Also erstmal hat er irgendwann da war der Thema mit der Zentrum für politische Schönheit, die hatten da gerade irgendeine Aktion. Da hat der
abends ein Foto gemacht von so einer von so einer Hippe war das glaube ich, also irgend so ein größeres Messer und einem Glas Bier und hat gesagt, wenn sie kommen, er ist vorbereitet.
Sieht sah aus wie Machete, also ich.
Ich wurde dann immer, ich habe dann immer gesagt, das ist ein äh äh das samir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen nach einem äh osmanischen Säbel aus, aber äh war dann wurde ich,
aufgeklärt, dass es denn doch irgendein deutsches Messer ist oder sowas. Wie dem auch sei. Dann hat der,
Also der hat äh eine ganze Menge an Unsinn geredet. Der ist ja dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr tragbar gewesen aus dem Rechtsausschuss rausgeflogen. Und jetzt ist er natürlich bei den Maskenverweigerern, ja? Und hat in der deutschen Bahn.
Ohne Maske da irgendwie solange Theater gemacht, bis sie die Polizei geholt haben und dann hat er sich.
Mit einer Nussecke.
Mit einer Nussecke in der in der in der auf der ICE Toilette versteckt vor der Polizei.
Er wollte nur was essen.
Er wollte nur eine Nussecke essen auf der Toilette im ICE. Ja, wo die also ein Mensch, der in der Lage ist, in einer ICE-Toilette eine Nussecke zu essen, ne.
Ich wollte was ganz anderes erzählen, aber der Brander ist natürlich eine Figur. Der der Punkt ist nur, wenn man nicht Berufspolitiker ist und sozusagen noch nicht mitgekriegt hat, welche Selbstverständlichkeit diese Partei im Bundestag ist, dann ist das noch was Komisches, wenn man als Sachverständiger in den Justizausschuss
Ausschuss kommt. So war das bei mir und der Furzen ist seitdem AfDler. Und im äh ich fand das interessant,
dass einfach nach vielen Monaten die anderen Parteien gewissen Umgang damit gefunden haben. Für mich war das neu. Also ich bin natürlich auch nicht jeden Tag in diesem Raumschiff Bundestag, ja? Und also da,
ich will das nur als Beispiel sagen für diese Verschiebung. Wir haben uns daran gewöhnt, dass die größte Oppositionspartei im Bundestag, die auch immer zu ihr spricht. Ähm,
Die AfD ist und dass die auch letztlich treiben sie
Politik vor sich her, das sieht man jetzt an dem Beispiel Moria, also du du siehst ja wie die heute wieder plötzlich über Flüchtlingspolitik reden und dass dieses Grundrecht auf Asyl ist ein Schickenshit geworden. Also das ist wirklich, der hat sich
seid, merke diese berühmte Wir schaffen das, gesagt hat, was ganz doll verschoben. Und ich finde, die Behandlung,
dieser dieser rechten Netzwerke in den Polizei und übrigens auch mal vielleicht noch nicht vergessen in der Bundeswehr, ja und in den Geheimdiensten, ja.
Dass wir einen irre lichternden Inlandsgeheimdienstchef haben, der plötzlich ein lauter Rechtspopulist geworden ist, der dicke Buddy von Seehofer und solchen,
und der Behandlung von den Opfern ganz konkreten Opfern solcher rechten Netzwerke, nämlich euch, die,
der ist da stellt sich mir einfach die Frage nicht nur nach so wolkigen Forderungen, ja was wollen wir denn da machen in den nächsten zehn Jahren, sondern da frage ich mich, was müssen wir tun? Jeder einzelne, der sich als
als sozusagen als normaler Mensch und hier als Menschenfeind fühlt. Und ich will jetzt hier nicht wieder irgendwas hören von Menschenrechtspässen, sondern ich will hören, was müssen wir,
konkret tun morgen und nicht irgendwann, wenn wir vielleicht mal in der U.
Du die Antwort hättest, würdest du mich das nicht fragen? Weißt du, dass es erstmal Nummer Ro eins? Hast du darüber selber schon nachgedacht? Was? Okay, dann sag du die Antwort, dann würde ich sie gerne von dir hören. Was müssten wir konkret tun.
Ich denke, dass wir letztlich, wir müssen uns äußern, jeder einzelne von uns. Wenn das jetzt Social Media gibt und es angeblich so eine Demokratisierung ist, dann müssen wir uns positionieren.
Und was ist, wenn das schon passiert ist und die Position ist das.
Möchte ich woanders aus.
Ja, aber das ist genau das, was ich meine. Und ich glaube, das unterschätzt ihr. Und es fällt euch auch schwer, weil ihr auf der anderen Seite steht. Guckt mal, ein weißer sucht sich seine Position nicht aus. Der ist da reingeboren. Aber am Ende des Tages wisst ihr eine Sache. Ähm äh wenn deutsche Rechte, da seid ihr nicht das Ziel,
als allererstes. Wir sind das Ziel,
Was dir so ein kleines bisschen eine Beruhigung gibt, dass das einfach tatsächlich für dich nicht wirklich gefährlich wird. Was natürlich ein Trugschluss ist. Es wurde ja gefährlich für,
ne, also massiv. Ähm äh aber man hat den Eindruck und mir geht es ja auch so. Ich habe auch den Eindruck und das ist das Gefährliche an dieser Zuspitzung. Ähm dass ich unter meinesgleichen die so aussehen wie ich
sicherer sei, als unter den äh äh unter denen ich weder geachtet bin oder geschätzt bin, noch so ähnlich aussehe wie sie.
Hm, nee, bei wat müssen wir denn jetzt so machen? Ihr kennt ne, ne, ne, das ist aber ein raus.
Nein und das meine ich, was du jetzt machst, ist eine Lösung irgendwie schnell, schnell finden, aber nicht darüber nachdenken, wo das Problem ist. Wenn du die Dynamik nicht erkannt hast, wirst du keine Lösung finden, die passt, dann wirst du eine PC,
korrekte Lösungen finden, die sich gut anhört. Aber eine, die verst,
was das Problem wirklich ist, das ist das was wir jetzt tun müssen, uns damit auseinandersetzen und zwar jeder auf seine eigene Art. Und ich sage dir eine Sache und das ist einfach eine Realität
Mensch, wenn du in ein Gelager gehörst, wirst du denjenigen immer etwas gütiger angucken als jemanden, der dir angeblich fremd,
Und deshalb ist dieses Mensch sein und das in den Vordergrund zu stellen, ist die einzige Möglichkeit, wie wir das auffangen können, weil ansonsten wird diese Scheiße sich nun drehen,
zu sagen irgendwie ähm ähm na ja, bei denen ist so, bei denen ist so, das wird uns nicht weiterbringen oder äh wie soll ich dir sagen, wenn ich's, ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, warum kann man mich Passdeutsch nennen? Warum kann ich nicht zur Polizei gehen und sagen, okay, ich zeige das an, äh dass mich hier,
Passdeutsch nennt, ich bin 'ne Deutsche. Eher mit seiner Verbalität sozusagen beleidigt er oder entzieht mir mein Grundrecht
Das darf er nicht machen. Ich bin hier zugehörig, er darf für meine Zugehörigkeit nicht äh in Frage stellen. Darf er nicht. Warum, warum geht das nicht? Kann ich mal zur Polizei gehen und Charakter anzeigen, weil das nicht im Polizeiregisse ist? Leute,
Das können wir nicht alles ignorieren und dann denken, wir haben eine Lösung parat. So funktioniert es nicht. Du musst dir erstmal abgucken, was das Problem ist. Und das ist das, was ich sehe, was nicht passiert.
Wir müssen uns angucken, was hier passiert. Wir müssen uns angucken, warum der Deutsche überhaupt nicht mehr die Möglichkeit hat, sich zu reflektieren. Ich meine, äh achtzehntausend Sendungen darüber machen, ob der äh Islam gefährlich ist, was natürlich lächerlich ist,
und mir dann erklären und es kommt ganz oft von den Medien, ja aber die Leute, die wissen das ja nicht, das müssen wir erstmal erklären. Nee, wir sind nicht alle dumm
okay, da äh zu meinen, dass dein Publikum dumm sei, ist schon eine Art und Weise daran zu gehen. Äh äh sorry. Warum fragt sich keiner, warum haben wir als Deutsche
Angst vor dem Islam. Das wäre die korrekte Rangehensweise. Wahr und das ist das, was passieren muss.
Eigene Reflexion darüber, die eigene Reflexion, wie geht es mir und wie fühle ich mich damit? Und nicht immer alles versachlichen, weil das Ding hier, was wir hier haben, das ist eine emotionale Nummer
Das ist keine versachliche Nummer. Du hast Gefühle, wenn wir das Thema aufbringen. Ich habe Gefühle, wenn wir das Thema aufbringen, aber aus irgendeinem Grund haben wir es noch nicht geschafft, die Miteinander zu verhandeln, weil diese Gefühle quasi entgegengesetzt. Ich löse sie bei dir aus, also wie ich kacke, du löst sie bei mir aus, also bist du,
Wenn wir das schaffen zu sagen, okay, das sind, das sind wir alles selbst, Tatsache, es ist so und wir können eine Distanz finden, wie wir darüber zu kommunizieren können,
dann können wir es hinkriegen, aber ich sage dir, wenn jetzt ein wirtschaftliches Problem gibt, dann kannst du egal welche Lösung du da hast, das würde mich,
Und das ist auch genau das und das will ich dir sagen. Diese Lösung schnell eine Lösung zu finden. Ich finde das toll, ne? Aber ich sehe, das macht,
bringt es nicht. Äh ähm guck mal, ich als Migrantin hab immer wieder Angst oder migrantisierte, hab immer wieder Angst, dass man mir meinen deutschen Pass wegnimmt. Warum?
Bei den Juden auch gemacht. Was ein Scheißdreck wäre.
Verstehe ich ich verstehe was.
Stehst du was ich bin ich kann dir nur meine Perspektive sagen. Ansonsten kann ich nur sagen müssen wir rassistische Handlungsweisen kriminalisieren das ist 'ne Tat die wir tun das könnten wir umsetzen.
Ja? Wenn wir das aber tun, wie willst du es kommunizieren mit der Bevölkerung? Das klappt ja schon beim DL äh AG nicht. Da klappt's ja schon nicht,
äh äh hier nee, ich habe fast eine falsche Anti äh Diskriminierungs. Es gibt doch jetzt dieses neue Bundesgesetz. Äh nicht Bundesschuldigung. Ber.
Antidiskriminierungs.
Schon da gehen die Leute auf die Barrikaden.
Werdet nicht ähm ich habe, ich habe das glaube ich ein bisschen anders gemeint. Der Punkt ist, also ich verstehe mich auch schon immer, seit ich äh so sagen aktiv bin, auch als Aktivist. Ich kann mich schwer mit Fahrt abfinden, wenn man,
äh eine Analyse macht und sich überlegt, also was ist jetzt hier passiert? Was findet das Großverschiebung ist das? Und dann noch so einen konkreten Fall hat, wie das jetzt bei dir ist. Wo man ja auch,
klar Defizite sieht und auch strukturelle Probleme, ich kann mich schlecht damit abfinden, dass man nur das Problem anfasst und nicht mal versucht,
Ohrenmacht, die denn ja in einem aufkommt umzusetzen in eine aktivistische ähm Agenda in dem Sinn, dass man was tut und zwar nicht.
Ist Cancel, Culcha nicht 'ne aktivistische.
In Gedanken führen und nicht sagen, die da oben müssten mal und Forderung hat die.
Die schon stimmen, aber nicht sofort umgesetzt werden kann, sondern ich hab immer den Wunsch, die Ohnmacht, och,
Damit zu beenden, dass man selber konkret was machen kann in dem eigenen Umfeld, siehst du?
Da würde ich immer hin, ich kann die Leute nicht aus so einem Podcast entlassen und mit dem Eindruck, eh kann ich tun, der bleibt jetzt so, sondern ich will immer wenigstens eine Idee haben, was kann man jetzt machen, ja?
Also ich kann dir okay, okay, jetzt habe ich dich glaube ich verstanden. Ähm äh was kannst du machen, wenn du ein weißer Mensch bist,
glaube, dass es ganz wichtig ist, was vielleicht auch nochmal benennen. Äh ähm definitiv setze ich damit auseinander. Ähm ähm was es bedeutet, in dieser Welt weiß zu sein. Das ist für Deutsche was Neues.
Wir waren bis jetzt immer Deutsch, jetzt kommt der Begriff Weißer auf, das wurde natürlich auch aus von Amerika äh ist ja auch eine
Dings allgemeine Macht. Äh ähm tatsächlich ähm äh gehen wir jetzt in eine andere Art von Unterscheidung. Und ich glaube, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, was das bedeutet, einmal für dich und was es bedeutet für alle Menschen, die nicht weiß sind. Das ist ähm glaube ich eine ganz, ganz wichtige Sache. Und da,
man, glaube ich, dann auch äh quasi in eine Entwicklung, die begünstigt, dass du die Dinge auch klarer sehen kannst, aber jetzt sage ich dir eine Sache, warum ich das sage. Du, du hast natürlich Recht, wir müssen alle bei uns selbst anfangen, ne? Ähm diese
was ich aber sehe, was wir haben, wir haben eine ganz alte politische Riegel, die nicht bereit ist, er auch nur annähernd forschungsnah zu arbeiten,
wir haben Forschungsergebnisse, auch das wollen sie nicht. Sie wollen willkürlich arbeiten und dann und Seehofers Satz ist dafür ein Ausdruck. Dass es nicht mehr darum geht, dass sie wirklich von Soundision, erzähl uns irgendeine Kacke und.
Zu machen. Für die sind wir Kindergarten, für die sind wir hort. Und das ist ähm äh
Da sehe ich ein ganz großes Problem. Und ich rede nicht von den kommunalen Politikern, die meisten kommunalen Politiker machen tolle Arbeit, als ich gerade in Berlin die Linken machen mega Arbeit. Deshalb bin ich auch sehr oft bei denen, äh vielleicht nicht in jedem Bereich, aber zumindestens sehe ich sie sehr bemüht,
äh eine SPD, die irgendwie sahzinder äh äh drin lässt, äh verstehst du, was ich meine? Warum ich den Willen generell in den Strukturen und,
in den Leuten, die sie ja ähm quasi via die Handlungsmacht haben. Ich sehe den Willen nicht. Der Wille ist nicht da, der Wille ist gute PR zu machen, genauso wie die Polizei sagt, gute PR machen es wichtiger, als dass es,
läuft. Das ist das Problem. Solange wir diese Art von Denken nicht raushaben
wird es gute PR bleiben und dann wird auch unser Grundgesetz gute PR bleiben. Was wir einzeln machen müssen, ist uns das Grundgesetz reinziehen, wir müssen uns zusammentun, wir müssen dieses Grundgesetz interpretieren, wir müssen zusammen machen, wir müssen mehr darüber reden, wir brauchen Sendungen darüber, wir brauchen Bildung darüber
wie wir konkret das Grundgesetz umsetzen wollen. Was heißt das? Konkret, wenn die Würde des Menschen unantastbar ist, heißt das, dass Moria geht,
echt.
Was mich ärgert,
reinerseits ein Satz reinwerfen und du rennst durchgegend, ich bin Menschenrecht, ich komme aus so ein Land, ich bin super und auf der anderen Seite gehst du dann ein Gericht weiter, sagt jetzt kriege ich nee, also das ist jetzt Auserlegungsfrage. Das ist fies, das Hinterhalt. Das ist so ein bisschen so, ach
denen eine Story, womit sie sich gut fühlen, aber wir machen dann sowieso unser eigenes Ding. Ähm wir sind eher an der Macht. Sie können eh nichts machen. Was können wir denn machen?
Offenkundig hast du ja nicht resigniert, also trotzdem du die Probleme auch benennst viele. Also da könnte es bestimmt auf.
Nicht in allem liege ich auch nicht richtig, bin auch nur.
Hast ja nicht resigniert und du hast ja eine gewisse Werf und och so, weiß ich nicht, eine gewisse Energie, die nicht, also dich nicht nur nicht einschüchern zu lassen, sondern auch zu sagen, ey, das gehe ich mal an, das benenne ich auch öffentlich,
was können da Leute vielleicht von lernen? Also mir geht's wieder um diesen Punkt. Also dass man jetzt nicht in so einer Unmacht versinkt in so einem Gefühl äh boah, da kann ich nicht machen. Ja, wie machst du denn konkret, dass du dich nicht unterkriegen lässt.
Äh ich glaube, dass was vielleicht äh wofür ich auch wirklich einstehe, ist zu sagen, es guck mal, es ich finde nicht alles toll an mir. Aber was ich über die Jahre wirklich lernen musste, um überhaupt zu überleben, ist das, was ich scheiße an mir finde, auch zu lieben,
Und äh wenn du gemacht fühlst, dass du dich hinsetzt und sagen kannst, ey okay, ich bin jetzt ohnmächtig, das fühlt sich so kacke für mich an, aber ich liebe auch mich im Zustand der Uhnmacht. Ich esse okay, ich darf da sein. Es ist in Ordnung.
Ist jetzt ein sehr künstlerischer, weißt du so.
Das sind verschiedene Ebenen. Aber jetzt ist die, die Sache, du kannst aus ein aus bestimmten sehr logischen Ebenen keine Lösungen finden,
also in der Intalektualität sind nicht alle Lösungen verborgen. Du musst manchmal die Ebenen wechseln. Deshalb spreche ich ja, wir sind multidentitäre multidimensionale Wesen. Wir müssen lernen, verschiedene
Ebenen nicht zu durchmischen, aber sie zu verwenden. Ähm ich ich sage, wenn und das glaube ich auch.
Vielleicht sage ich, sehe ich's in zehn Jahren anders. Aber ich glaube, wir sind in einem Prozess kollektiv als Menschheit,
wo wir lernen müssen, aufzuhören mit diesen äh äh du bist schuld,
böse, du bist Kacke, du musst Glas, du musst ins Verlies. Soll ich dir mal sagen, was ich mir wünschen würde, wenn wenn's einen Mord geben, was ich mir wünschen würde, was wir für eine Judi,
tiefe Ebene hätten. Ein Richter sollte nicht kommen und sagen, die Strafe kriegst du bis jetzt im Knast für die nächsten zwanzig Jahre. Sondern das und das meine ich mit, das wirklich zu begreifen. Hier ist ein Mord passiert. Hier sind zwei Systeme, das des Opfers, das ist Täter. Das Einzige, was der Richter zu entscheiden hat,
ist welchen Heilungsprozess werden wir für diese Familie angeben. Welcher Heilungsprozess ist der Richtige? Welcher Heilungsprozess ist gebraucht für diese Situation,
können wir da machen, damit beide Systeme ausheilen können. So, wenn wir darin bleiben zu sagen und deshalb sage ich dieses, ne? Das ist eine schwierige Sache mit der AfD. Da bin ich echt herausgefordert, ne. Äh was würde ich mir für einen äh äh Strafmaß wünschen, für einen, der Walter Lübke umgebracht hat,
dass man und ich sag's dir, auch bei mir würde ich mir das wünschen. Alter, steck ihn nicht ins Verlies, steck ihn nicht in den Knast, sondern versuch rauszufinden, warum er,
so weit gehen musste. Das ist ein verzweifelter Mensch, da ist irgendwas ungeheilt und ungeheilte Dinge bringen schlimme Dinge hervor. Meister Joda hat es schon gesagt. Jeder, der Star Wars kennt, weiß das.
Und ich meine das ernst. Ich meine das wirklich ernst, wir dürfen nicht, wir tun immer so, als ob das immer die
eigene Entscheidung ist, wenn du genau in diese Profile guckst von diesen Menschen. Die wurden selbst oft gequält. Oder sie haben äh Tendenzen von von
äh Satismus oder sie haben äh äh Eltern gehabt, die sie misshandelt haben. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir sagen können und oh das war aber alles immer eine klare Entscheidung. Das ist nicht so. Komischerweise fällt uns das bei Alkohol nicht schwer wahr. Wenn jemand Alkohol getrunken hat, dann ja gut, sie wurde verqualtscht, aber er war ja Alkohol, Strafmaß weniger.
Wieso ist das so? Warum sagen wir nicht, okay, Dicker, wir wissen, was wir als Menschen sind. Wir werden verletzt und dann verletzen wir weiter. Kaputte Menschen machen kaputte Menschen,
wenn wir sehen, wir haben eine Situation, wo das passiert ist, wie schaffen wir das, diese Systeme in die Heilung zu bringen? Ist die einzige einzige Möglichkeit für mich zu sagen, das ist menschlich und das ist zivilisiert. Was wir hier machen ist primitiv.
Jeder ist wütend. Und Deutsch ganz besonders, wenn man ständig den Finger auf dich zeigt und sagt, du bist schuld, du bist schuld, du bist schuld, du bist schuld. Was passiert da gar nichts? Schuldgefühle sind Alibi-Gefühle.
Aber jetzt kommen wir schon wieder, jetzt kommen wir schon wieder.
Da ist ja auch eine Menge, die ich noch sagen.
Weißt du, aber ich ich kann dir nur das ganz authentisch sagen, wie ich es empfinde und wie ich es sehe. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin auf einem super primitiven äh Planeten gelandet. Ich fühle mich hier nicht wohl. Ich finde das hier richtig kacke und ich leide da drunter
weil ich nicht, ich ich stelle mir eine Welt vor, die als Grundbasis und zwar alle
dass dein Essen, dein Trinken, dein Schlafen, deine Heizung, dein äh äh Strom, medizinische Versorgung, dass das für alle auf der Welt da ist
Abgebot und nicht hier irgendwie, aber die sind so, die sind so und dann begründet man das mit kulturellen Blabla. So ein Bullshit.
Jetzt gibt's ja tatsächlich von den Rassisten. Im Prinzip die Vorstellung, dass sie sagen, so ja,
Also argumentieren ein bisschen so, ne? Es ist halt so diese Martin Sellner Ecke, ne? Identitäre Bewegung und so. Denn sie sagen so, nee, wir haben ja gar nichts gegen die anderen Kulturen, ne?
Frau äh Grisch gesagt, das ist ja auch so. Wir haben gar nichts gegen die anderen,
Ich hab nichts gegen Ausländer im Ausland, ja? Äh, die sollen einfach wenn jeder wenn die einfach alle so bei sich bleiben, dann können wir das hohe Gut der unterschiedlichen Kulturen erhalten. Man kann auch mal im Urlaub hinfliegen, aber man hat die,
nicht bei sie vor der Tür. Ja ähm und das argumentieren sie im Prinzip als die leichtere, die einfachere Lösung.
Was hältst du davon.
Also ich glaube, das hat, also wenn wir in die Geschichte gucken, war das noch nie so. Das hat auch noch nie so geklappt. Es gab immer Leute, die woanders, also sowas gibt es nicht. Es gibt auch kein homogenes Volk. Äh das ist Quatsch.
Bin dafür, dass wir sowas wie wirklich genetische Herkunftsteste einführen sollen, ganz besonders bei Menschen, die ähm Nazis sind oder so, dass man mit ihnen einen genetischen Herkunftstest macht, damit die sehen, dass es sowas wie,
homogen, deutsche Gene nicht gibt. Also ich glaube, Nazi, der versteht, dass er Italiener oder Türke ist, eventuell und die es gibt viele Ossis diesen Türken, weil unsere Leute hier zweireich gefahren sind,
Damals sie konnten ja nicht rüber, egal als ein anderes D
aber wenn sie sehen würden, dass das ihr genetisches Material, also wirklich was handfestes, ähm äh nicht homogen Deutsch bestimmbar ist, macht das was mit dir,
Du wirst es nie wieder vergessen, zu italienisch in dir hast. Du vergisst es nicht. Und das macht es ein bisschen schwieriger. Weißt du, so eine Nummer zu fahren,
tatsächlich geht es ja hier eher um Macht. Es geht
es geht um Macht an sich und ich glaube was wir verstehen müssen ist wie in Macht als Dynamik funktioniert. Weil das sind austauschbar. Martin Sellner kann morgen äh äh Ali Gündos heißen,
dass es austausch,
es geht um darum, äh was für einer Dynamik befinden wir uns. Macht eine Dynamik, die etwas mit dir macht. Extremer äh extremer Armut macht krank, richtig?
Was glaubt ihr denn, was extremer Reichtum macht? Glaubst du, macht dich gesund.
Alles außer Balance, macht krank, alles komplett alles und wenn wir das nicht kapiert haben, dass wir hier vor allem Wandel stehen, der so grundsätzlich ist, der,
eine neue Art zu denken fordert. Hier gibt's nicht nur um irgendwelche, wir sind am Ende damit. Hier geht's nicht um irgendwelche Ideologien oder um irgendwie äh ähm,
irgendeine Meinung oder irgendwie äh es war früher schöner, es ist heute scheiße. Hier geht's um ein ganz, ganz, ganz definitiven äh neuen Anfang darüber, wie wir über uns als Menschen denken,
Sonst schaffen wir das nicht. Ich sage dir das, sonst wären wir im Bürgerkrieg landen. Das ist so,
Und da wird der ganze Mist von weitergehen. Und dass wir natürlich auch eine einen Zusammenhang haben zu neokapitalistischem Verhalten, Neokapitalismus ist Faschismus.
Also wir haben's über die.
Ja, ich war ich versteh.
Ja, aber Entschuldigung, das ist das Schwierige, ne? Also wie soll ich das erklären, wenn ich das nicht irgendwie auch und es ist nicht mal, ich habe wirklich nur minimal versucht, daran zu gehen, mit den kleinstmöglichen, aber es ist wahnsinnig vernetzt, es ist unglaublich intersektional.
Ist leider auch auf der persönlichen Ebene. Jetzt hat Linus gerade den Sender angesprochen,
Wir nehmen mal dem seiner Zweispeile offen, kundig war der ja ein Idol äh von dem Crastchurch-Assentäter. Also bisher gibt ja eine Ebene,
Natürlich kann man sich über universelle Menschenrechte und über unser Menschenbild unterhalten, aber es gibt ja diese konkrete Ebene, die du ja in gewisser Weise jetzt auch repräsentierst, ja.
Der Typ mit dieser Ideologie hat jemanden anders zu ganz konkreten Gewalttaten angeleitet, ja? Und es gibt ja auch in deinem Fall offenbar äh Leute, die das so richtig zu einer konkreten Bedrohung werden lassen und ich.
Wir kennen mich nicht so richtig damit abfinden, dann immer sozusagen auf die Ebene zu kommen, weil wir grundsätzlich als Menschen untereinander besser machen müssen, sondern ich finde, das muss gerade auch für diese konkreten Fälle wie euch jetzt die also und natürlich auch äh Janine und also
ja die NSU-Anwältin ist ja glaube ich noch der krasseste Fall von allen und so.
Weißt du wie sich das für mich weißt du wie sich das für mich anhört? Das hört sich an wie die fünfhundertste Sendung in die anfängt mit dem Satz sind wir wirklich rassistisch,
Dieses, wir müssen was machen. Wie lange sagen wir das jetzt schon,
fällt uns was wirklich Konkretes ein, jetzt mal allgemein. Ich meine, es ist, ich spreche ja nicht nur mit dir. Dieses, wir müssen was machen. Diese Ohnmacht äh ähm
selbst wenn wir auf Ideen kommen, konterkarieren wir sie, weil wir sie auch nicht wirklich zulassen. Die, die ich habe, ist ja nicht meine Idee, die ist mir, sie ist ja nicht persönlich meine Idee
sondern es ist eine eine etwas worüber ich nachgedacht habe, lange nachgedacht habe. Ähm äh und das als einzigste Möglich.
Sehe, weil wenn nicht, wiederholen wir das einfach nur, was wir vorher gemacht haben und dann wird es äh dann mal besser und mal nicht besser. Hier ist etwas Grundsätzliches, was sich ändern muss und auch ändern kann,
weil wir jetzt am Ende sind von einem Zyklus. Wirklich, wir sind am Ende mit etwas. Äh wir kommen da wirklich nicht mehr weiter und wir kommen auch nicht so auch nicht mehr weiter. Tatsächlich müssen wir anfangen,
darüber nachzudenken, wie wir grundsätzlich unsere Sichtweise auf die Welt und auf uns verändern. Grundsätzlich und zwar so forschungsnah, wie es irgendwie geht, denn wir haben Forschungsergebnisse
die dir ganz klar sagen, Jana selbstverständlich leben wir unter gewissen Gesetzmäßigkeiten, es gibt hermitische Gesetze, äh das sind universelle Gesetzmäßigkeiten, die wir nicht anwenden. Ähm äh ich meine, meine muss man doch mal sehen,
ähm äh das deshalb meine ich mit der Struktur ist das so wichtig. Aha okay, wir sind also wesentlich haben Spiegelneuronen, wir passen uns der Umwelt,
Das heißt, wir müssen gucken, wie gestalten wir die Umwelt, damit.
Stehst du was ich meine? Das sind ja alles Dinge, die ähm ähm ich versuche das so ganzheitlich wie möglich zu sehen und zu sehen, was macht die Natur, was macht der Körper? In der Regel machen wir das auch. Äh ähm und wie können wir das für uns nutzen, dass wir eben nicht,
in so eine Situation kommen. Und da sage ich dir, wenn Nationalität weiterhin Nummer eins Identifikation einer Person ist, die geboren wird, haben wir ein großes Problem.
Ja, an Nationalitäten binden sich Rechte. Nicht wahr?
Richtig. Das heißt, wir müssen also eine Rechtsgrundlage finden für alle Menschen, denn dieses Globale, wie willst du das denn zurückdrehen? Also es würde ja auch bedeuten, guck mal, das, was Martin Sellner sagt, das ist Kolonialistisch,
Die Kolonialisten haben genau das gleiche gesagt. Wir haben ja nichts gegen Schwarze. Haben wir ja nicht. Aber die sollen gefälligst da unsere Baumwolle pflücken. Das ist das Problem.
Also es ist ziemlich genau, ich würde jetzt auch sagen, er hat einfach nur einen die finden einfach nur einen schönen Weg äh rassistisches Gedankengut irgendwie äh nicht mehr ganz so schlimm dastehen zu lassen. Das ist einfach nur eine eine ganz gute PR, ja. Ähm.
Schade, dass wir das Problem jetzt nicht gelöst haben.
Ja. Die werden jetzt nicht gelöst haben. Nee, aber es war auch nicht zu erwarten. Also come on.
Guck mal, ja was, ich meine, was soll ich, ne? Wir können ja nur gucken, was kann ich auf der politischen Ebene fordern, was kann ich auf der rechtlichen Ebene fordern.
Wie kann man dich denn konkret unterstützen? Also äh können wir nochmal eine Ebene tiefer? Jetzt weiß man net oder wir nehmen, können noch Janine nehmen oder Martina Renner ist ja egal. Also wir.
Nein, nimmt mich. Ja.
Würde zum Beispiel helfen, wenn die ganzen Nazis mal dein Programm anguck.
Er könnte helfen ja tatsächlich.
Ey der kommt, Klischees überzeichnen ist doch und überhaupt Kunst kann Kunst kann noch retten oder? Absolut.
Sehe ich auch tatsächlich an, ich finde tatsächlich dein Programm so oder deine beiden Programme, wenn ich oder deine beiden äh Freundinnen ähm.
Nicht vergessen, wir sind hier zu fünft, ne?
Sehr schön, dass hier also die die spielen auch mal so ein bisschen die Absurdität vor. Also so Frau Grischke ist tatsächlich jetzt ein nichts besonderes.
Leider nicht, nee.
Hier überall rum. Die die sitzt in jeder Ecke am Fenster.
Jeder kennt eine.
Ja und Grischka hat sich auch gewandelt, ne? Also auch Grischke wird ja erzählt äh oft von beiden Seiten. Sie wird ja nicht nur schlecht erzählt, sie wird auch gut erzählt, weil Grischke war auch eine
Die losgegangen ist und äh gesagt hat, Frau Eiche, sie verstehen den Brief nicht vorab. Kommen sie mit
wir gehen da zusammen hin. Sowas gibt es nicht und dann geht die da rein und dann sagt so, Frau Schneider und sie bearbeiten jetzt hier den Antrag. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein, Frau Eicher hat zwei Kinder. Wie lange sollen die auf ihr Geld warten? Frau Asche, regen sich nicht auf die Kapsel im Griff. Ah, ich gehe bis zum europäischen Gerichtshof, wenn sie das Tier nicht auf die Reihe kriegen. Das ist auch Christke,
dürfen wir nicht vergessen. Das ist die Griske mit der sagt zwar Mogli, komm her, aber die gibt dir auch einen Lolli.
Und Ordnung Krischke.
Richtig, aber äh damals wollten die das noch für alle. Heute ist ganz klar, dass diese Leute das nur für eine bestimmte äh Menschengruppe will,
Das ist das Problem. Das ist das Problem. Recht und Ordnung wird den Migranten abgesprochen. Äh die äh schöpfen wir ab,
deren Leistung schöpfen wir ab, verkaufen sie als unsere äh ähm das ist kolonialistisches Denken und solange wird das in der Bildung auch nicht reflektiert haben, Bildungssystem, auch ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Warum warum kommt das dann nicht vor,
Warum gibt es wirklich äh schwarze Führungen, die sagen, guck mal, das ist Kolonial, das haben sie von uns geklaut. Da haben sie mit uns Scheiße gebaut, da wollten sie uns aus Stellen im Zoo, warum wird das nicht gemacht?
Na es beginnt ja, ja, diese ganze Restitutionsdebatte, die.
Aber ähm Entschuldigung, es gibt immer noch in Sachsen Bücher, die von die rassistisch äh Nationalitäten erklären
die werden noch benutzt, also nützt uns das eine nicht, wenn es im anderen da gemacht wird. Ja, also was bauen wir jetzt einen recht rechten Osten auf? Und ein Multikulti-Westen oder was wird das? Also äh das bringt auch keine Einheit
ja? Also äh das heißt, was kann ich also wirklich konkret tun? Ich kann entweder versuchen, an diesen äh Institutionen
ne, mit denen mich äh zu beschäftigen, wie Janine Wissler das macht, sie kann's versuchen auf der politischen Ebene, ich kann's versuchen, auf der medialen Ebene, auf der künstlerischen Ebene. Äh ähm Julius kann's versuchen, auf der äh judikativen Ebene, auf der Rechtsebene, ja, also aber.
Well und wir machen hier Medien im weitesten Sinne. Medial.
Natürlich, natürlich, ja, das heißt also, was können wir da tun? Und dann und darüber haben wir jetzt gerade zwei Stunden gesprochen, was passiert, wenn du das tust. Was passiert, wenn du das tust.
Was passiert, wenn du das tust? Das ist unser Problem. Das wir sagen, was tun wir? Wir haben das Problem besprochen, dann sagen wir, was tun wir wieder? Es funktioniert über diese Ebenen gar nicht,
Es funktioniert nicht, wenn ich zur Polizei gehe, weil die Polizei dran beteiligt ist, mich zur Bedrohung zu kriminalisieren. Es funktioniert nicht auf der politischen Ebene, weil ein Seehofer äh äh Dings Marie an Toilette spielt und dem das scheißegal ist, was hier läuft,
mir leid, das ist so offensichtlich scheißegal. Hätte mir eine in die Fresse geklatscht, wäre nicht so schlimm gewesen, wie dieser Satz, wir brauchen kein Rassismus, da ist Studie, das ist verboten,
Ey, sag mal.
Wobei also.
Schon nicht mehr lustig.
Medien haben aber auch wirklich alle oder so gut wie alle geschrieben, was das von uns sind. Also ist ja nicht so, dass er wird ja schon.
Ja, aber ist jetzt was passiert und das meine ich. Wir sitzen hier immer noch und stellen uns am Ende der Sendung die Frage, was sollen wir machen? Mit diesen Organen, von denen wir denken, dass die dafür zuständig sind, dass wir mit ihnen arbeiten können, haben wir gerade zwei Stunden eroiert, dass das nicht funktioniert.
So Lino, so können sie jetzt mal abmoderieren und zwar positiv. Versuch's mal. Versuch's mal, versuch's einfach. Irgendeiner muss es machen. Wir kriegen's nicht hin.
Ich gucke mal, ich sage dir, was ich mache zum Beispiel. Ich höre nicht auf, mit euch zu sprechen. Ich höre nicht auf euch zu achten und zu schätzen. Äh ich höre auch nicht auf, euch zu kritisieren und zu beschimpfen, mache ich nicht,
aus dieser Rolle heraus. Am Ende des Tages weiß ich, dass wir ey, wir sind ja alle groß geworden, ihr wisst es, ich wisst, weiß das, aber auch ihr und das, das müsst ihr euch wirklich klar machen,
Rolle nicht aus. Ihr seid in dieser Täterrolle konstruiert,
ohne dass ihr das wollt und es macht Schuldgefühle und zwar massiv. Schuldgefühl ist wirklich eines der miesesten Gefühle auf der Welt. Und das müssen wir miteinander kommunizieren.
Wir wollten ein positives.
Es ist positiv. Lasst uns miteinander immer noch reden, so wie,
jetzt hier machen. Wir reden miteinander darüber. So oft haben wir aber nicht darüber geredet und so aufgeklärt ist diese Gesellschaft nicht. Bitte einmal wieder Realität. Es ist nicht so, wir sind schon auch ganz schön primitiv.
Oder wir lassen jemand anders abmoderieren.
Frau Grischka hat heute noch relativ wenig gesag.
Ja, also ich kann nicht sagen, ist ein Quatsch, was die sagt. Die sollen einfach raus. Dann ist hier auch wieder alles super. Und das äh ja, die, wer schützt uns,
glaubst du, die Moluken schützen uns? Die nehmen uns so aus, die kommen hierher, die wollen unser Geld. Ja, das geht doch nur um Geld. Entschuldige, das geht doch nur um Geld,
vermehren sich hiermit ihre komischen, minderwertigen Gene äh mit uns weiter, ja? Äh Entschuldigung mal. Äh äh wie tief sind wir gesunken, dass wir nicht mehr verstehen, dass wir äh einfach ein hochwertigeres Volk sind, das kann schon so gesagt
Leute, das ist Kultur. Das ist, das nennt man äh ähm äh zivilisierte Gesellschaft, ja? Ich verstehe nicht. Also ich bin dafür, die müssen alle weg, tut mir leid.
So, det wäre jetzt das was frisch gesagt.
Sagen ist ein super Ende für die Sendung, oder? Ich würde sagen, dass so ein super Ende für die Sendung.
Super, ja und nee. Stell dir mal vor, da schneidet einer raus.
Nee, nee, das ist das, das ist Ende der Sendung jetzt.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne, wenn man mich mit Griske, dann kann ich ja auch vor Nazis spielen, die lieben mich,
aber wenn ich mit Gilette von Nazis spiele, dann sie hassen mich. Ist doch auch interessant, die gleiche Person. Wenn sie das sagt, Chriske, liebe große Liebe, bitte Präsident. Wenn sie das sagt, bitte sofort vernichten, ist doch interessant und umgekehrt ja genauso.
Die also Nazis gucken sich Krischka an und sagen finden das gut.
Ja, nee, die hat doch richtig Frau.
Sehen die gar nicht, dass.
Nee, auch bei bei Gilets sehen sie's teilweise nicht. Da sagen sie, ach ja, hier und det ist der Grund, warum ich AfD wähle. Das ist der Grund.
Aber das ist doch schon ein bisschen überzeichnet, muss man doch merken.
Das sind schon Leute aus meiner Show rausgegangen und haben gesagt, das ist der Grund, warum ich AfD wähle.
Ja, ja, ja. Weil wir sind da noch gar nicht. Also, ihr seid sehr viel progressiver als ihr, ihr glaubt, dass der Rest ist,
Das ist nicht der Fall. Wir sind diejenigen, die äh diese Progression vorantreiben, das ist tatsächlich schon auch eine gesonderte Situation. Ja, ist so.
Also es ist ich sag ja nicht, dass die Mehrheit ist, die Mehrheit ist das nicht, die Mehrheit steht nicht auf und geht, ja, aber es gibt diese.
Und ich glaube, ganz oft sitzen sie auch da und sagen gar nichts, weil sie das schon sind, aber es auch nicht zeigen wollen, ne? Also weil es ihnen dann erst auffällt und ich glaube,
müssen wir einfach auch zulassen, dass da ein Entwicklungsprozess steht. Aber ich sage euch ehrlich äh und das ist die Realität auch, es ist auch nicht negativ, aber ich sage mal so, es ist auch nicht explizit positiv. Wir kommen in eine schwierige Lage jetzt
ist es tatsächlich so. Und wir müssen was tun und da befreue ich mich ja, dass du das sagst, was tun, ähm aber was können wir noch tun,
was wir tun, ist ja schon. Cancel Culture ist für mich ein Ausdruck davon, dass wir das versuchen. Ja, macht.
Mal anders, pass auf. Wer diesen Podcast jetzt gehört hat und die ganze Zeit durchgehalten hat mit uns. Der sollte zunächst mal zur Weiterbildung,
sich unbedingt äh die Programme mal ansehen oder zumindest Ausstätte davon und dann möchten wir mal aufrufen zu einer konstruktiven Kommentarkultur,
Und wir machen es, die Fragen, die wir hier nicht beantworten können in Bezug auf das persönliche Verhalten, was man jetzt eigentlich tun muss,
bitten wir doch unser Kommentatoren mal in die Kommentare zu schreiben, womit machen.
Wir haben unser nee, ist ja nicht YouTube.
Das wird lustig. Wir haben gesagt, nee, ist ja nicht nur. Wie? Ah ja, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Sorry, ich habe vergessen, ja.
Völlig in Ordnung, also nee, nee, unsere Kommentare sind äh.
Wir haben die jetzt hier auf zwei Plattformen, also einmal bei Lockbuchnetz Pultik und einmal bei Netzfultik Punkt org und wir werden mal sehen, wer da so rumkommt, oder? Ihr besprecht ja sozusagen in eurem nächsten Podcast dann noch öfter mal das Feedback, ne?
Ja, können wir machen? Ja, finde ich gut.
Na ja, das wird schön.
Vielleicht können wir der Idee nochmal dazuschalten.
Ja, also jederzeit gerne.
Also ich bin für jede Schalte bereit.
So, dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob das jetzt die Leute zum zum Kommentieren an äh äh motiviert oder nicht. Ähm.
Ja, wir können uns jetzt erstmal nur bedanken.
Ich danke euch. Wirklich es ist wirklich toll, auch so engagierte Menschen zu treffen.
Es war wirklich ein Fest, sich hier zu haben. Ähm.
Wer vielleicht ein bisschen weniger lustig, als wir gehofft haben, oder? Also weil ist ein ernstes ist ein blöde.
Ist ein ernstes Thema,
Ja, wirklich, weil ich meine, weißt du ganz ehrlich, Walter Lübke ist gestorben, wie viel Lachen können wir da noch? Weißt du, das sind die Leute in Hanau sind gestorben, wie viel lachen können wir darüber noch? Wie können die auf den aufklärerischen Prozess lachend gestalten, das können wir ruhig machen, aber am Ende des Tages ist es bitter ernst.
Komik ganz schnell tragisch. Und äh ähm ja, wie soll ich sagen?
Wünscht mir das nicht und wir werden das auch schon irgendwie hinkriegen, davon bin ich überzeugt. Da, das finde ich gut an dir, dass du da, da hältst du den Kurs. Das brauche ich auch. Ich brauche jemanden, der den Kurs hält. Ja.
Bin mir ich bin mir bei einer Sache auf jeden Fall sicher, dass die die also diejenigen, die gewinnen werden, werden die sein mit mehr Humor.
Für das halte ich für tatsächlich
sehr, sehr notwendig. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass man irgendwie die die ganzen Leute mit ihren schlechten Gefühlen irgendwie abholt, indem man ihren Hass,
befeuert und so und dass dass man die da auch eine Zeit lang von überzeugen kann, aber die werden schon irgendwie irgendwann müssen die selber merken, dass das.
Du kannst ja auch die Nazis nicht mehr ärgern, als einfach nur dadurch, dass du ein schönes Leben hast. Also das ist so der einzige Grund.
Ah
Warum ich ein schönes Leben habe. Nur um die Nazis zu ärgern.
Ja, das kann man natü.
Wenn du noch ernsthaft in wirklich nochmal so richtig richtig lachen kannst. Ja. Ja, das wir kommen eh mit Humor, ja, mit Humor zu unseren Zielen, das ist doch mal toll, oder? Aber man Linus, du hast ein schönes Ende.
Humor, den die noch nicht mal verstehen.
Ja, mit diesen Worten, meine Damen und Herren, Zuhörer freuen wir uns über eure Disziplin uns die ganze Zeit zugehört zu haben und warten auf eure Kommentare und verbleibe mit freundlichen Grüßen, Tim.
Und Linus.
Ideal und geiler, ja, hier und Frau bitte. Und ich bin Gilette, Vola, ich bin schon gar nicht mitzuworten, ich konnte gar nichts mehr sagen, was soll ich noch sagen? Aber komm in meine Show, dann ich sag alles.
Super, vielen Dank.
Tschüss ihr Lieben, tschüss, bis bald. Ciao.
Ciao, ciao.